[Music]
ah
hello hi i'm louis hello nice to meet
you i'm from the bbc today's guest is a
hero of mine and lawrence's great
documentary meg thank you it's louis and
i understand that you're in touch with
celestial beings space creatures the
whole point of the koalinga program
wasn't like let's go and hang out with
some pedophiles and see what they're all
about it was actually that made you
laugh he said just for the record let me
make it very clear i am no longer
attracted to children that's what you
would say do you know that you're not
attracted to children yeah that's good
reflection yeah pretty much
you're not gonna bite me is he no he's
not gonna bite my testicles it was
kicking off the kids weren't going to
bed and i just just started shouting get
into bed now
wow you're shouting really loudly you
must have really lost
and i felt like kind of ashamed i think
it's great that you admit that you've
lost it because you always come across
in your documentaries as the calm guy
god put it in your wicked heart you're
gonna eat your babies he's i'm not sure
how much i can do i've castrated myself
chemically no [__] way would i let
him out
no [__] way there's women out there
who are mad for you the world's smallest
subculture one of it was i didn't really
want to play the long game like hey
should we go out on a date i just think
hey do you want to come back kick back
and smoke some gang and if that didn't
go i know that i can go home and get
high and listen to some music and that
would seem much more appealing who is
the [__] the baby and he's gay for pay
is the term i said what so what did you
have to do you gave the guy [__]
yeah unfortunately and so i heard myself
say oh come on you enjoyed it right the
day after the program went out i write
back at my house the neighbor was quite
a grumpy old man and he and he said i
see this program and for this we pay our
license
[Music]
it's a fascinating world bodybuilding
yeah
because
there's
naturally there's so many narcissistic
people who jump into it yeah and they
want to be admired and all of that and
they're willing to basically risk their
lives just to have that crappy trophy
that to them means so much yeah but
nobody else cares yeah and the women
even more so yeah well the women are
permanently damaging themselves in a
different way aren't they because
they're it's irreversible what they do
like if a man comes off steroids
it's just
we're having more of what we already had
whereas a woman their jaw their hair
their
facial hair all the things that are left
it's irreversible they're clitorises
they've got clitorises yes are we
rolling when you say when you say that
is that a bad irreversible element or is
that good
jeez we're getting in deep yeah we're
getting we're starting with bigger
clitoris female bodybuilders here on a
woman then it'll be good it's a
preference
is that what you're saying well it might
be
um
oh should i even say you know chyna the
wrestler yeah yeah yeah yeah and um she
killed herself i believe mm-hmm yeah or
or it was an overdose of sort of an
overdose yeah it was probably aged about
47 48 something like that yeah that's
really sad and she was the pre
preeminent um
female uh wrestler at that time
and um
did a porn film
with another wrestler actually was it
yeah what was that it was x-pac who did
it yeah really yeah because she had a
relationship with triple h it was the
guy and triple h basically
chose stephanie mcmahon
and had a bit of a overlap there went
with stephanie
and then they moved china sort of out of
the business slowly but surely because
stephanie mcmahon
owns the the the wa doesn't she so she's
got that power they just
see you later and once she'd been phased
out
she turned to more alcohol more drugs
you could say she'd stop working out as
much and when he's she was appearing on
interviews
really out of it
uh like howard stern in places like that
you know
um
but yeah i remember watching because i
was like a young kid watching the wwe
and naturally you discover wrestling and
porn at a similar age
so i'm like
she looks different like something
different about what's going on down
there when she did play ball you know
well i was going to say so i stumbled on
it i don't know where on the you know
you're on the web and things pop up and
it was a screen grab
of her privates and and
the point that the person who posted it
was making was wow it's surprisingly
large clitoris
well it's meant to be the penis isn't it
it's meant to be the end of the penis or
the clitoris
meant to be
you know before you before you before
you go one way or the other it's uh
it's yeah that's it that's apparently
why we've got that dotted line between
our arse and our testicles could be a
vagina
that was what would have been the vagina
i'd have had a very pretty vagina post
fertilization there's a fork in the road
right yeah exactly and and the embryo
can go
a few different ways so i was going to
say a couple of different ways but that
would be that would be close-minded in
sorry i forgot i do the intro uh welcome
back to true jordy podcast
sponsored
the site going sharks um
yeah baby shock um uh welcome back the
true joy podcast sponsored by jim shark
and today's guest is a hero of mine and
lawrence's it's louis theroux great
documentary maker thank you and uh great
journalist i think is actually um yeah
well yeah that's what we should yeah
well i'm not saying i am by both those
professional terms are acceptable
great podcaster is very kind of you to
say and like an occasional podcaster
yeah you ever thought about giving
yourself an easier ride just jumping
into the podcast because then
because it's it's we've made a few
documentaries before and it's so much
work by comparison
to having a conversation with someone
and also you have the the following and
you see what people like joe rogan are
doing out there you could make a lot of
money doing a bit of an easier life for
yourself so here's me thinking i've
turned up for a podcast interview and
it's actually a business meeting
pitching yeah sorry louis what we want
is we want to do a three-way podcast
with you every week a new financial
manager we will produce you no problem
absolutely yeah you know it's a it's it
has struck me having done uh 20 episodes
of a podcast called grounded
which is still available available on
bbc sounds giving myself a little plug
and it
it was surprisingly easy and in my
book
i talked about wow this feels weird
um how
kind of
so relatively straightforward it is just
to
record this thing because i was doing it
remotely people didn't even have to show
up exactly my guests were just doing it
from their homes
and um
and then you put it out there and then
tons of people
would would re i got more feedback on my
podcast than i did for any tv i'd made
for the previous one at least for the
previous five or six years is that not
because it's easier to give that
feedback because of the formats of
podcasting whereas
besides the fact you have [__] ksi on
the podcast because you can get loads of
feedback is there a dog that's just yeah
sorry
get the bed
yeah you had our friend ksi on your
podcast what do you make of the new wave
of celebrities now because obviously you
went around talking all of the
celebrities uh you know when you were on
the come up and now we're met with a
completely different kind of celebrity
people who just have made come famous
from talking to their camera i think
it's extraordinary and full disclosure i
first became aware of ksi because my
kids who are now 15 and 13 but probably
this would have been a couple of years
ago told me it kept saying um ksi's
fighting logan paul which which would as
a sentence meant nothing to me do you
know what i mean the proper nouns
i didn't really recognize like what is
that who and why would they express
interest in a boxing match anyway that
was out of character for them and then
it turned out they were youtubers so
fast forward a few years basically i
realized there was this world of um
people self-created personalities who
were completely outside the realm of
normal media just uh existing through
their own channels coming up from their
bedrooms and that was and i dug into it
to be honest it took me a few uh watches
to get it like you don't sort of dip
into one ksi video and sort of think oh
i i get why billions of people
are
locking onto this because actually
a a lot of it is yeah it is almost by
definition homemade
and and and it takes a while to
appreciate what it is that the kids are
kind of getting about it but i i had
them on the podcast because i wanted to
reflect this new world of of youtubers
and internet people and
i think it's extraordinary isn't it
because it feels to me that the
um for the younger younger crowd kids
you know teenagers it's almost like they
are they're rock stars you know they
represent for them
something that they own like that that
generation is special for them it's
meaningful for them same as what punk
rock would have been
for example right if we didn't for me it
would have probably been rappers because
i i thought like mainstream rock or even
indie rock felt a bit square to me so
the world of rappers and the feuds
between rappers and actually there's an
interesting parallel because it was the
authenticity that i responded to in the
an east coast west coast beef right and
the idea of oh dre's fallen out with ice
cube now and actually uh you know now
tupac and biggie are beefing and
and it sort of felt like a soap opera
but also it spoke to a kind of community
that one aspired to be part of and that
you felt that maybe
you you kind of hanging out with these
older guys who are cool bit risky uh
quite funny but very talented and that's
a podcast there you go the youtubers are
sort of uh well we hope so right but
people can decide at the end yeah of
this episode um you know you felt like
um
that's what the the kids are into now
it's like is that feeling of um
authenticity i hate saying like that's
what they look like
you're spot on because it's people being
themselves and uh in in the world that
you came up in you probably were very
fortunate to get that break
which now people are sort of engineering
their own bricks you know as you know
we've been filming with ksi
uh for a documentary for amazon and i've
seen some of the rushes and the response
he gets from his fans
um
at the festivals is extraordinary just
chose in general it's extraordinary
it's like beatlemania it is yeah it's
crying you know i've been to a lot of
gigs but the level of hysteria yeah um
is is off the charts which i think it
speaks to what you're talking about
right and what we have been what we've
been talking about which is
people feel such an uh a kind of a
kinship with um they've watched him grow
up yeah and you can't we have quite
compare that to
you know let's say a huge supersonic
eminem in my generation was the guy
but i heard an album from him every
other year say yeah and but the
connection
if i if i'd been able to watch his life
every day it would have been even more
intense it would have been even more
like fandom and that's what he they have
now got that direct line to the audience
it's amazing just a little subject
change i'm just wondering like where
what are you into at the moment what is
your thing how do you relax ever of an
evening you know whatever's big in the
culture tv wise
i tend to give it give a go like
obviously squid game was huge recently
succession uh succession i binged the
second it was nice the third it was
third season what did you make of squid
game out with interest did you like i
found it very compelling like the first
couple i was like this isn't for me you
know it it has a sort of korean acting
style
or i don't know what you'd call it but
you know how it like called it bad like
different cultures have different
disorder distinct
almost like i don't know acting styles
and like you slightly exaggerated right
but then by the third one i was like
okay
this is pretty good and then and then i
went i went with it and i enjoyed it a
lot did you not like it i like the
concept and some of the things that it
made you consider but like the acting
was a bit wwe wrestling do you think
that like this is better when then there
were different tonalities later on and
did you make it as far as the marbles
yes episodes i watched the whole thing
yeah so the mob that there was some very
um
affecting like the bit where he's
playing marbles with the guy who's got
dementia
and then i thought that was really power
like some terrific dramatic
yeah that was a powerful moment for sure
so watching tv cooking is my other one
oh really yeah i love to cook what are
you cooking now because you talk a lot
about spaghetti and um
no i talk more well bolognese is what
you talk about no lasagna sorry that is
veggie lasagna as well yeah yeah veggie
lasagna anything that requires me to be
in the kitchen
uh where i can therefore be on my own
for a bit like it's you know have a
little break from the family and then
have a couple of drinks listen to either
a podcast what's what kind of drink just
i'm trying to get an idea of the way you
are here what are you drinking gin and
tonic so just the elephant in the room
is that i've got a book out and i talk
about a lot of this stuff and it's
called through the keyhole and it's a
very what's on all candy i read it all
it's fantastic a
almost revealing to the point being
slightly self-flagellating look at a
family man in his 50s being me
who who's possibly on the edge of having
a drinking problem i shouldn't laugh
when i say that's fine and yeah going
through the pandemic
and going slowly insane i think we all
as we all were and actually and being a
kind of
whatever the opposite of an exemplary
dad is like a disastrous dad in many
respects and a lot of it takes place in
the kitchen where i'm making lasagnas to
just escape from my three children and
have and be able to sort of drink
unobserved right let's get a few like
and it would be um so it's almost
sneaking them in
sneak sounds loaded but yeah but yes
that's why cocktails is good in the book
where i talk about hiding my
this isn't my coming out as an alcoholic
but this i talk about for the title
purposes it will be yeah yeah louis
through alcohol i do not have a problem
yeah exactly you can do
that what they do is they use the pull
quote the pull quote would be this isn't
my coming out as an alcoholic right
right
through in denial i must admit when i
watch the uh place for pedo's uh
documentary and one of them goes i am no
longer attracted of children
that's that's what you would say a
little bit that's what that is okay
actually just speaking of cocktail
moments that's actually one of my
favorite moments you've ever had in a
documentary and i wanted to know whether
mr kitchens was his name he said just
for the record let me make it very clear
i am no longer attracted to children
yeah but that's not my favorite moment
in that documentary he also goes to be
like how do you know if you are
attracted to children do you know that
you're not attracted to children yeah
that's good reflection yeah pretty much
yeah
the best bit in that documentary is when
you go in and you they're having the
party and the guy's mixing the drink and
you go over to him and he said and you
say what are you in for he gets me to
taste his lemonade right first of all
which is a nice icebreaker yeah and then
in the way that you know there's certain
opening lines that like if you're a
casino the opening line instead of
saying hello you go like how are you
doing are you winning are you winning
you up are you up are you and then in in
a prison you go like what are you in for
and then also in a as it turns out
maximum security hospital for pedophiles
and sex offenders what are you in for
and he do you remember what he says he
says um
along the lines of uh i'm in for date
right yeah he says date rape which is
and i couldn't work out if in that
moment because there's times in the
documentary we were talking about where
sometimes you see your eyes go brilliant
we got the clip sort of thing uh with
that was that a moment that's how we
interpret it
you might be thinking oh that's
interesting but we want the juices you
might think you're [__] poker face
but we've got you sussed is what we're
saying yeah in that moment did you sort
of go
well that's fantastic uh you know
i may have done i i can neither confirm
nor deny it wasn't like there were many
moments on that um shoot where i was
like this is extraordinary there was
another when they um
do you remember at the same party it was
a halloween party and and the singing
contingent there's a choir at the uh the
hospital and they they decide to sing
the adam's family
yeah
the thing is the crazy thing about that
guy the alleged date rape guy is he say
alleged even now well right here's my
point is that i would strongly suspect
it was something
uh worse than date rape that was him
kind of dialing it down
i've got to say something that doesn't
sound wildly like uh uh like he's not
he's obviously not in there for postage
fraud right but um it might also be you
don't end up with koalingo um
for a single date rape right you've got
to have two index offenses and and by
the way as you i'm sure you know the
term date rape is um considered
offensive you know it's like well it was
a date and it went wrong it gives the
wrong impression he was undoubtedly in
there for a violent um
a violent sex crime yeah yeah and so
allegedly yeah it was i think it was
worse right i see what you're saying
you're not trying to dial it down you're
actually yeah you're giving him more
credit than he did there was one
conversation that stuck out in in my
head from that one is where
you asked the guy
was was that the one where um your son
want you off for example and and he's
like no no that never happened he goes
oh man ah i went off and he was just
there right yeah that's right yeah and i
was like easy mistake i mean that's not
funny it's not funny but that same guy
he was i can't his name was mr yarn you
had to call him mr it was one of the
rules one of the strange places about
that um the strange things about that
place was that um
because they were uh patients not
prisoners they they were they you know
it was a requirement of the of the
hospital that they extend certain
courtesies right they weren't there to
be punished they were there to be
kind of medically reformed and so they
couldn't you know so one of the things
that well even the term patient they
said well we prefer that we think that
term is a bit demeaning so i said what
do you call them so we call them our
residents and um and we always address
them as mister so then i just got into
the habit isn't it i mean like the
accident
[__] though really like they they
they're trying to
nicey nicey something that isn't nice at
all and the problem is is their
attraction makes them a permanent danger
for the rest of their lives to
what the rest of society holds theorists
which is their children and then
you know they're all dialing it down and
claiming i'm not i'm not in for that bad
thing and we can reform these people you
can't reform them this is why he's
making the docs and you're not but in my
head i'm watching thinking
none of these guys come across as
anywhere near reformed even the ones
you're about to release something in no
[__] way would i let him out
no [__] way
you should take my until you're next in
a sense that um the hospital is a um
what's the best way of putting it like i
think it's it's a de facto warehouse in
the sense that very few people leave um
the the not more people get out on legal
appeals
than get out having graduated from the
what they call the phase program of
rehabilitation
when i was there and had been going
about seven years they'd had about 10
something like that actually leave and i
think the p the problem is is you can't
coerce people into therapy like they
they're there thinking like i'm not here
to be released i'm here to be just kept
behind you know i've done two prison
terms
and then the authorities are like we
can't [__] let that guy out what are
we gonna do like okay why don't we have
this law called civil commitment and
it's a bit like a section where we say
your dangerousness as a pedophile
means that you're mentally ill
now by many other metrics they wouldn't
be considered mentally ill like they're
not they don't experience any kind of
psychosis uh they they in in most
respects other than being deviant sex
offenders function right they're
functional they can keep jobs down right
if they try to use that for example as a
plea of insanity they'd never get it no
exactly for that reason so but but for
the purposes of keeping them behind some
kind of uh security facility they they
are deemed to be kind of medically
unsound and the legal term is sexually
violent predator and so that they're put
away and and then and then the uptake of
the therapy
is is extremely low like only a small
relatively small minority of people that
take part in the therapy so like for the
others they're just going around playing
squash making lemonade
singing the addams family theme that was
quite interesting but can i ask one
question about when you were
interviewing one guy
it came across like so he was going
other therapy and actions speak louder
than words and i was watching him like i
was mr yeah
this guy
you could almost feel a bit sorry for
him right because i wasn't when i was
watching his interview i wasn't aware
of what he'd done i think i don't know
if i was paying enough attention or if
it had been clarified yet but the point
was he was coming across so compelling
in his well he spoke with a kind of
exaggerated courtesy like he was
deferential and it was like he was he
was
his affect he was like oh yes well one
wonders if what he was he's doing he was
actually when i first met he was making
a a ferris wheel out of bits of card for
kids like a kid's craft project sure and
then he was spinning it around saying
like well when the wheel does spin it it
reassures one somewhat that one has done
it correctly which is rather a good
feeling and so he had this sort of
punctilious way of almost like um i
don't know how to describe it like like
a a waiter at a really posh restaurant
that's or or or it was disarming and
reassuring
you ever flown first class and the
flight attendants
they're so sort of like almost like
um
attentive that it's faintly like it
makes me quite tense right yeah i have
to reflect back your level of
attentiveness and then i'm oh yes thank
you ever so much do you know what i mean
yeah the point of it is to relax you but
because you can feel you're trying to
relax me your brain goes i'm not
relaxing this is extremely tense now
yeah i had that he's on first class
feeling really tense even when you get
to business there's a level of tension
but i imagine in first class it's like
really tense oh my god but you i think
but if you're like um
i don't know like rupert murdoch or
richard you're probably you're like yeah
bring me another one yeah but uh yeah
this time don't stin you know a little
more vodka but if you're like if you're
like us and you're sort of trying to be
a decent person you think oh i better
give back what they're giving to me i
was once in it doesn't happen often but
i've been upgraded a few times and once
you know they're like oh we like your
programs we think we can make you a
little more comfortable so they bring me
up into like business or first and they
lay you out like on a full like a full
like a flat bed like a which is the
dream on a long flight you get a flatbed
and they have these are you too big for
the bed or are you no they're about sick
they are a little i'm six feet two and a
half and they're about that it's like
just
right
so um
so then they they they had these new
beds and they're like so pleased to show
them off and i there i am lying i know
we can tuck you in would you like me to
take out the duvet sir oh that would be
great they'll tuck you in and then like
eight hours fly by and then we're coming
into land and i don't know if it was
well i i'd done something wrong and i
was like i was having trouble you know
like something's quite confusing
operating yeah like this the buttons and
levers on on on a plane and then i'm
like oh how do i release it so i'm still
lying down that so i hit my flight
attendance button and i say like i can't
make it go back to a seat so then
they're like oh oh so sorry sir oh just
be one minute and then they're leaning
over me and then i don't i think i'd
broken the [__] lever or the button
so then they're like levering it and
then
he gets his mate so then there's two or
three of them
like bending over me and i'm there
and then they're like they can't fix it
and they're like oh sorry so you're
gonna have to come into land
lying down
i don't even know if that's legal i
don't think that's right i'm still i'm
feeling awful like
they upgraded me i broke their bed and
now here i am looking like a total
planet coming to land at heathrow lying
down with my seat people walking past
louie thinks he's up
exactly yeah
my question basically was were you like
look this isn't therapy this isn't work
and you're just trying to
say whatever you need to say to get the
hell out of here
and it's i said
you know what i had a little showdown
with him in the last scene of the film
where i was like i'd actually
uh read his clinical notes uh at that
point like the first time i met him
i hadn't read his clinical notes it was
only two days in to the shoot i was
realized oh we're allowed to read their
clinical notes
so the first couple of interviews i did
with some of the contributors um i i
hadn't read them i don't clinical notes
might not be the right term but whatever
i had more background on what he'd done
and then i i realized for the first time
that he had two daughters he'd been
married and that part of his grooming
process had been getting his daughter's
friends over and putting them in the
bath and that would lead to the him
abusing them that was a preamble to his
abuse and you know when you read
um
you know i'm very much like take people
as i find them like it's part of my
process in a way to sort of arrive in a
space and and try and size someone up
and figure out
based on how they
react with me and how they behave like
what i make of them and ceo and call
them on stuff that i've seen i try
not to dredge up stuff too much but
clearly if you're talking to a criminal
or
or or a pedophile
you know they can come across very
plausible and what you realize is that
you really need you you absolutely have
to be briefed and so two days in i had
more information i realized what his
offense pattern was and he i thought
he'd been very open in some respects he
had he told me like oh i have 54
offenses mostly involving boys in their
teens like those weren't convictions
those were things that he'd revealed in
therapy which is another reason they
don't do therapy a lot of them by the
way is because it can lead to new cases
because you're supposed to be open in
therapy like and actually if you've been
convicted on three counts of this
involving two boys but actually you've
abused 50 boys right
then they're think like why why on earth
would i disclose that in therapy when
that could be used against me in a
future case anyway you're in for life
anyway though so uh not technically
because he's not there on a conviction
he's there on a medical right for a
medical rehabilitation right that he
could come out on in theory at any time
and in fact anyway he so i challenged
him on his offenses a bit more robustly
and he got crossed like you saw his um
whatever sense of vanity and narcissism
like behind his
accentuated uh sort of humility humility
was a kind of a
a a sort of a narcissism and an and and
he put his back up a bit and he got he
got annoyed and i think you saw a bit
more of of the real person he's i'm not
sure how much i can do i've been at home
let hear me out on this i've been in
here for five years i've castrated
myself chemically in order to which gone
beyond what was required of me i have
made account of every thing that i've
done so i feel that and then his
therapist was there and she was she was
sort of giving me the evils like
what would you expect mr lam to do in
your in your um words to own up to what
he's done like what would you expect
from him so then i'm
i mean
in a sense um i felt a little bit bad
for him because i was just there was a
part of it that was just
creating a moment for television like i
was conscious that i need to be seen to
um give this guy a little bit of a of a
grilling
and then he's sort of obviously upset
and reacting badly to give you and then
last year i made four series four
episodes of a follow-up show about
various things i followed up on him he
was one of the people i got back in
touch with oh wow and he had been
released
uh about three years after i was there
and then um fella foul of the process i
don't think he'd
done any new crimes but i think he he'd
failed to register
and i think they'd intercepted some mail
for him that they felt was inappropriate
and he was back i can't remember he was
back he was back behind court by the way
like
you know you've got the internet there
and you're getting mail sent to you like
that's that's not give them i think he
was in jail he was in jail on something
having failed to register he said my car
broke down or something then he sent a
letter they intercepted the letter
anyway bottom line he's back all the
guys who were doing really well in
therapy it was mr lam and the legend and
and mr rigby was another mr rigby was
back in prison on a new case
he'd molested there was one guy who
you've seen had an inappropriate picture
that was mister
no not one inappropriate picture like a
series of inappropriate pictures where
he went i wouldn't there's one the best
bits because you've got his case worker
there at that time yeah and they go and
you go would you say that does he look
like he's a teenager or is he not a
teenager and he's like well he looks old
enough to me
and you're sort of in this gray area and
then even the caseworker seems to want
to back him and sort of go well he looks
he looks fairly adult to me
yeah that was a the thing is is i mean
we could talk about kawalinga that's the
name of the place
for the whole podcast but because it's
one of the most extraordinary people say
what's the weirdest place you've ever
been in the sense koalinga is it because
of the collision of the the sort of the
dangerous psychological profile of the
people who are there but also the
weirdness of the institution itself
right you know mental health processes
many of them are imperfect at best which
isn't to say
you know a lot of it doesn't work but a
lot of it is is um you know inexact you
know what i mean we don't unders the
brain is mysterious and the idea of
curing people like whether it's
medication or therapy or these are all
to some extent still being figured out
and when you're talking about a
dangerous like an ingrained um
groomer and abuser of children and then
you're attempting to use
sort of aa style therapy or group
counseling therapy
uh to address that it's really
kind of putting a plaster on a gaping
wound and also having them all together
to me normalizes so much of what they've
all done when they're talking there was
one guy who went yeah i think most of us
in here are he had like a um yeah that's
the problem a spanish look to him uh
like a gangster kind of thing yeah yeah
and he was like i think most of us are
saying here and i'm
watching that thing and that's because
you are all together good what are you
in for and it's becoming like that's not
a big deal right
he has a point in a way like in a sense
like
he's saying like we've committed crimes
but we're not meant to yeah he was right
in that sense
so in a way it's sort of like his point
is um uh we're being held for future
crimes like we're being held for crimes
that we may commit in the future but
we've all done our terms we've done our
probation and our parole
and and like until we commit another
crime who are you to say that we're
mentally ill and then well they would
say well
uh two psychologists have deemed you to
be medic you know dave
dangerous
but it it it is a kind it's a slightly
awkward because most paraphilias which
is what pedophilia is like you know
people have sex with cars people have
sex with vending machines right people
dress up they're left with they're not
left with um it's the car isn't left
with a terrible memory no they're not
sure the car is not traumatized
although you might need a new exhaust
unless it's kit at which point you know
right so as a society we've made the
decision rightly
that those those um paraphilias that
leave victims in their wake are treated
more more more severely or more
seriously but in in strictly medical
terms
um it's not actually a mental illness
are they not just being kind to that
because that's what i kind of thought
when you made that point i was a bit
like listen they're being quite kind to
you here they could have put you in an
institution where there was no chance
rehabilitation they could have put you
in this in the institution and basically
gone lock them up and throw away but
they could legally they couldn't but
they could but the the legal system
could just do that and they could just
say
change the certainty basically
pedophiles are so dangerous that there
is no way to rehabilitate them but there
is but those laws i mean they have to
pass a whole new set of laws they're
working within the laws that exist but
he was sort of arguing and i get what
you're saying but what i mean is the
system could just go these people don't
deserve a second chance and actually
it's as bad as murder you've taken away
someone's happiness for
20 30 years of their life that's as bad
as murder which a lot of people probably
would regard as that will lock you up
and throw away the key i'm not
necessarily making the case for that but
i mean he's then sort of taking the piss
by going well is it really that bad and
you sort of say in your book i think a
lot of them kind of justify it by
speaking about things like things from
ancient greece and things like that and
they try and find ways of
um normalizing normalizing yeah no well
here so so what what i think people were
faced with like the the authorities were
faced with was the fact that
historically um sentences for child
abuse and pedophilia were like
relatively low certainly by today's
standards so we're talking about i think
uh
those people that most of people that
coaling quite old like was rare to see
anyone under 50 most were in their 60s
70s and 80s
and um
so there are people who've done things
that they would have done a lot more
time they can pass all the laws they
want now and i think many of those laws
have been passed
but um they were dealing with people who
were coming out of prison now and they
had people that they wanted to lock up
now and they needed a legal framework to
do it the other thing though is the cost
of keeping them there in those medical
facilities is enormous like it's it's
it's over a hundred thousand i think he
said 200 grand a year so yeah yeah 200
grand here per guy with like 700 in that
one i mean it's just millions
and um some of them are in their 80s and
and 90s right
i mean
i mean and actually um there we go
sorry i forgot where that was right yeah
yeah
and so they are do you think people will
your audience get the reference no
that was achieved that was a totally
innocent reference really was it though
but then you know when you've watched
something and because obviously i've
been watching all your stuff yeah things
just creep into your brain absolutely um
actually i wanted to talk to you about
your drink problem more okay uh what is
your dream of choice when you're
borderline drink problems borderline
drink well you sort of have a solar
issue don't you yeah i just like whiskey
right that was my other thing i was
going to say that so
during the pandemic
i was drinking uh bourbon kentucky
bourbon good choice and and and i got
into something called bullet which an
american friend had introduced me to
it's not expensive it's it's a
relatively like you thought you might
find they sell it in my
we're co-op mm-hmm
live in northwest london you're really
selling it i mean they don't i've i
worry like actually a little party was
like i'm talking about bullet a lot in
my book i wonder if they'll send me like
some free bullet but i almost prefer
that they didn't so i can keep a kind of
dispassionate distance from it because
because actually um christmas is bad for
that isn't it where you just get
everyone gets you whiskey
yeah and so you know if i have i
actually i was gonna say if i had bullet
in the house i'm having a dry january
okay good for you so i'm feeling quite
smug i'm two days in i i didn't stop
back monday was a bank holiday so i oh
you can't start on a bad holiday no it's
the way it works but where are we on
thursday so tuesday wednesday
i i haven't had anything to drink and
i've got some bourbon in the house but
typically like if i had bourbon house
like i'm like [__] i'm gonna have
some how many glasses of whiskey can you
get through in the night and still be
like
i don't know what was the most for you
where you're just like i don't really
keep tabs but um wow you really are gone
in the book there's several times when i
um
i talk i don't use the term
uh blackout but there were several times
when i would wake up
uh
on the sofa or on the spare bed and and
not quite remembering yeah the last
couple of hours
like
for some reason january 6 the night of
the insurrection
i got mullet
um i think there was a lot going on you
know and yeah and a part a lot of the
people involved in
you know what was going on at the white
house
um were people that would be not some of
them were people we'd been in touch with
for documentaries and had been in the
process of making a documentary about
um you know members of the far right
groups and i was saying this is so weird
what's going on over there and and and
also i just so i had a couple like all
of us it's hard to reconstruct i mean it
was only like was it a tuesday night
wasn't like a particular was a weeknight
and um
and i remember i'd also heard that
oliver stone had heard a podcast that i
did that he was in like he'd listened to
and he said something really nice about
it and then i'd listen to a thing i'd
done with fka twigs a rough cut and i
was like that sounds good like a few
little things that happened that made me
happy uh la catie guys
on tv and i was watching this frog
freezing and i remember that this is
this is the most incredible thing i've
ever seen on television like the frog is
freezing but it's still alive and then
you sort of defrost like a black like a
block of ice and then became they were
rip it rip it it came back to i thought
i thought this is the most extraordinary
thing i've ever been seen on tv and then
i had a couple more drinks but your
question was how much i don't know quite
a lot though yeah you're a big guy as
well i think those big guys we can we
can put it away
i love the fact that you are watching
attenborough yes to me you two are like
you make different stuff but you are the
two best-known documentary makers in the
world well it's not nice to be
considered in the same breath i one of
the proudest moments almost
most surreal moments
of my career was a few years ago
when i we i was
i was asked to plug things for an it was
a new app or a new platform or maybe
just an iplayer push and they're like
talk about things that you liked on tv
that are on iplayer and i can't i think
i mentioned
uh probably
uh league of gentlemen and uh you know
one or two other things and um uh
and i and then they showed me the
attenborough one and he said yes i enjoy
the young mr theroux
and and and it was like the idea of of
being um given a seal of approval
by him he's sure he didn't mean justin
through for what he's done in hollywood
well you know
until you said that but he's i don't
think he's on the i player that's a good
point yeah
you've got him on that one yeah
he also
that's unbelievable that like for you is
he's the godfather of the the game isn't
he he's the dawn yeah i mean he is ill
capo de tucci yeah every time he tries a
great reference yeah every time he
trends people are terrified that
anything's happening because obviously
he's getting to know their age we're
just like not him yeah he's the best
that he's kind of i think that's
twitter's biggest
they're basically they must be prepping
for that day at twitter just lining
servers up for tweets about david
attenborough when he finally does you
know pass on to the next yeah natural
world what kind of music are you louis i
you know a bit of everything i would say
almost everything
like i listen to a lot of at the moment
grime and drill because really yeah
because my kids are your kids
mainly because my kids if i were in the
car they insist on um is there one
artist in particular uh well aj tracy
good choice central c mm-hmm uh he
central sea seems to be
kind of
but yeah so blowing up right now um who
are you like some of the white guys like
h and uh rd yeah ardy's got a collab
with um central c at the moment i think
were you
is this do you think it also sounds like
real life music factual pain music do
you mean so did you you like hip-hop
back in the day yes i did yeah it's hard
to keep up because artists the turnover
of artists in the rapid hip-hop world is
is quite fast much higher now
well back in the like in the i you can
almost say it's lower now in the sense
that when i was coming up in you know in
the late 80s early 90s the golden age of
hip-hop and there were artists
uh like uh i mean
epmd
uh d people you may not even d nice
um uh bdp
uh which was krs one but big daddy big
daddy kane
borderline that was yeah vpd but similar
the big daddy kane had like two
extraordinary albums he had a third that
was so so and then i think a fourth that
was dreadful even like the the the the
kind of premier uh emcee of of the of
the time eric b
uh yeah
was extraordinary and he was royalty and
he had like three really strong albums
but then he fell off and it was almost
like that was the
it was like you only really in this
world you only really get to be
the big man for a couple of years how
did you but then later just
but then later it felt like oh well
someone like um
i i don't know if it was uh
nwa that changed the template because
they like some of the ice cubes stuck
around and then jay-z stuck around and
then it's like oh no oh now you can be
like rock stars like the road now you
can be like the rolling stones yeah
snoop dogg and all of them and you can
snoop dogg and they're still they're
forever artists but that's not
yeah still dre did you watch um
um the defiant ones no i i mean to watch
it oh you'd love that yeah i would love
god i would love it i was too busy
drinking bourbon in the kitchen i spent
two years sort of not watching
as well it sounds a bit weird but not
watching as many docs as i would like
more or less because i didn't i was sort
of it was hand to mouth in a sense in
the you know with respect to just
domestic chores work commitments
parenting and then the only tv i could
watch was stuff that involve the family
and i i can't always get them to sign up
to a documentary so this the covert
situation locked down to all of that
one of my mates who's got three kids
basically said to me
it was driving him insane being
surrounded by like he said i love them
but i can't [__] do this like it's
doing my head in now and
you drinking and stuff like that and
telling us how you are like how was it
for you just going through that time and
and also how are you feeling about the
world right now
because it's it seems weird like we were
kind of told
get the uh get the vaccine and we'll all
be okay to get back to normal and now
we're like still have this sort of thing
hanging over us as a society how is it
making you feel well to the first
question
you know you have to acknowledge uh i
have to acknowledge like i had it easier
than most in the sense that i'm i'm well
paid we've got a nice house
um
i don't have those insecurities but it
was horrendous you know like from from
where i was sitting like
the experience i had
was um
just the this what what i have to hold
on to because you get further away from
it and you it dims a bit
and you sort of remember that there's
some more positive aspects but parts of
it i found totally um almost
incapacitating and specifically was the
feeling of having a young child at home
and i think anyone who's listening to
this or watching this
who had young children at home who
weren't in school during the lockdown
while also attempting to do a job from
home we'll recognize this and you've got
a deadline or you've got someone who's
expecting something from you or an
important call and then you have a small
child who who's too who's too young to
really be independent or to be able to
um take care of like homeschooling on
its own
and and they're kicking off and and
actually it's a really it's a very weird
and upsetting feeling because it feels
like it's a combination of
sadness and rage i don't know if there's
a word for that sage sage it's despair
it's it's utter anguish and um
you know um
because you normally have such control
over your life and now it's like and
it's almost like and also i'm haunted by
the idea that people have of me or may
have me that i'm someone who's so
relatively um
sort of you know in control of his
emotions like still recall or has some
degree of equanimity right and then here
i am thinking like i i want to go
[__] punch a wall or just smash an
object over my head you know what i mean
there was a few times when you shouted
at your kids in your own book and stuff
and then
i shouted so loud one night this is
shameful no but this is healthy here
from people who aren't who sort of the
point of writing the book was right i
want to own i don't want to write a book
about my personal life
it was almost like an antidote to the
previous book where i was talking more
about my professional life but glossed
over aspects of how difficult i find
many things about my work-life balance
and um just being a present dad and and
husband and and so i thought you know if
i if i maybe the point of this book is
just to sort of
reveal the ugliest part of how i am in
the domestic setting and so there was
one night when
i can't remember it was kicking off the
kids weren't going to bed and it was uh
it was just kicking off and i and i just
just started shouting
and it was that weird thing where you're
shouting and then there's a little part
of you going like
like there's a little sane tiny
homunculus in your brain going like wow
you've really lost it
do you know what i mean yeah like
they're still sane like he's become very
small yes because the other voice is
overpowering yeah yeah and he's like
he's saying like wow you're shouting
really loudly you must have really lost
it
and then but you're still there and you
go like get into bed now
and then um
i went back to bed i remember lying on
the bed and got like this is weird like
my heart is beating
so fast and i felt like
kind of ashamed yeah and and i've had
this sort of adrenaline dump from the
rage
and um
and you know if you're if you're married
or you have a significant other you know
they it's almost like a tag team moment
like
time out like get in there like you know
like you switch switch out and and and
and i like so i looked over nancy my
wife and i'm like oh i think i lost it
didn't i and she's like yeah yeah you
did you tapped out basically i tapped
out like maybe can you handle it you
know like traditionally
dad is the the last resort mother is the
first result yeah you know when it's
really bad i'm gonna get you daddy uh
what kind of role did you pick up what i
realized is that one of my um
sort of pinch points like
psychologically when i feel most under
stress
is when i feel like i'm caught between
my wife and my kids and and my wife said
something like um you know you need to
handle that or or or
they're being too loud sorted out right
or or i just feel like i've been given
them it's almost like um
you know when dogs get stressed and they
say it's like when they have insecurity
about who the leader is and i don't know
i don't even think that's a good analogy
but i just mentioned that because it's
like you know they start they're like
unless you're up they go i don't have a
pack leader i guess that means i'm the
pack leader i better bite everyone in
sight do you know what i mean
um you bite your kids
fighting my kids no so then i go in and
the kids are acting up and then and then
i'm feeling like i've been sent one
mission right which is to make sure the
kids are quiet or get them in their
shoes or get them in the bath and and
it's not happening and if it was if i
didn't have the top level sort of if i
didn't have my orders
i'd be like fine whatever [__] it i
might be or i'd be i wouldn't feel that
i'm caught between
if you put the pressure on yourself it
wouldn't be that bad that's the fact
that nancy but you can't go back to her
empty handed i feel you'll get a result
here i need like i'm i'm in the middle
management position caught between
like two countervailing forces you're
tim in the office it's extreme maybe so
like yeah a6 i don't remember him
screaming and shouting
no but he just about keeps a level on it
but here's the point is that as a result
the next morning i woke up and my vocal
chords felt really weird and then
through the course of the day my voice
disappeared and then didn't come back
for three days and for three days i
thought that i professional broadcaster
podcaster
had actually sort of gone julie andrews
do you remember julie andrews lost her
voice i don't think she maybe that was
from shouting at her kids i don't know
but um i thought i think it's great that
you admit that you've lost it because
you always come across in your
documentaries as
the calm guy who in the face of a
screaming nazi or whoever you manage to
always hold your nerve and it just shows
that even you between as you say caught
between kids and a misses can lose it
yeah and i think that's great i found
that quite a lot in your book where i so
i've had a wife about six months now and
it was quite insightful because
everybody
had a what sounds like a car we ordered
her off the website she was fantastic
she had a wife it could yeah so with any
particular wife crossover she's lovely
um so we we've been we've been together
for about 10 years but now we've we've
been married the phrase would be like
i've been married for about six weeks
right okay yeah i'm it's difficult to
find a normal phrase but the point is
right she uh we've been married for that
time and i found there was a
particularly insightful chapter in your
book which actually i listened to is an
audio book where you're talking about
being present as a father yeah and how
your wife
says some of the similar things to what
my wife currently says where it's like
you know you're not around enough for
all these kind of things yeah and how
you ended up dealing with that we
actually so i listened to it on my own
but i actually sat her down and we
listened to it together and kind of
laughed our way through that because i
was like this was like therapy because
you were saying in a way it kind of does
work out but one of you does make some
sacrifices yeah
it was quite interesting to listen to
though how how how much you do reveal
about yourself because i think
in your previous book before that you'd
almost gone the other way were you gone
i don't like to people that's wrong too
much about it and in fact i've got three
books and the first one i'd say almost
nothing about yeah anything personal
that's why i was struck by and then in
the middle one which is uh gotta get
through this yeah i talk a bit about um
the home front battles on the home front
and
struggles over um me being away a lot
for work and then i went all in that was
sort of the whole point of this one
through the keyhole was to own up to
shorts of uselessness in the domestic
setting and that feeling of like people
say you know how the question i probably
asked more than any other
um
you know when i do q and a's and stuff
it's like how how do you stay i got to
off how do you stay so calm when talking
to these
ku klux klansmen or or or racists or
cult crazy cult members what do you say
and and what i always have is this sort
of um it's like guilty feeling of it
doesn't really require a great deal of
effort and if anything
i i have to g myself up to be
confrontational like my natural setting
in in work mode
is sort of quite passive which i think
it can be a strength in fact maybe
um
uh one of my
sort of um qualities is a journalist
that's allowed me to get into places
others haven't and create programs
others haven't and and is that i don't
feel a strong urge to take people on if
people say things that are kind of
controversial or outrageous what i'm not
thinking like that's wrong like stop it
i'm thinking like oh how interesting i
wonder where that comes from you know
tell me more that's your superpower
maybe yeah
my weakness do you think weaknesses are
superpowers in general but both yeah so
for example if i was to try and do the
same thing this like i have a a much
more threatening appearance and
therefore
they would be
less likely you're cheating because
you're showing off your tattoos
yeah if you if you had your short
sleeves yeah intimidating
the
you have this chameleon effect on people
where you can slip in
and
not
be that um
person who they're going to look at and
go i can't tell him this in case this is
the reaction they accept you and you
uh
it's genius the way you never apart from
scientology i believe you've always been
invited by these people
in and it's not one of those things
where uh they're not willing
participants they're
they're understanding well to a degree
they're understanding what they're
getting themselves into and one of the
things that struck me when i was
watching all of your work was if you
ever look back on it and feel a bit look
some of these are what i would call bad
people like
you know these religious nutters and and
racists and people who hate gay people
they're terrible people
but at the same time they are people and
a lot of them probably were
oblivious to what they were really
getting themselves into it's not like
where me and you were talking here and
we know this is going to be seen by a
lot of people and you you know what it's
happening and i know what's happening
fully some of them didn't and i wondered
if you ever had a little element of
uh
was that the right like you know because
now they're forever
that
yeah and it's everywhere forever you
know yeah i mean
in a way um
dealing with that and thinking that
through was
um a process that i went on through the
course of um
the first five years of making programs
right and and i i came
into program making
via um
being a correspondent for a tv show
called tv nation that was hosted by
michael moore and michael moore is a out
now satirist who's
whose mission in life is to sort of set
the world to rights by um satirizing the
bad guys
and sending them up and and and also not
to sound weird but i always liked prank
shows and you know for me
things like candid camera beetles about
happy game for a laugh later trigger
happy but although but trigger happy was
like so that wasn't formative for me the
form the ones that were formative that i
then thought i and that i thought that's
that that's that's the that's gold kind
of like bora originally yeah yeah
or indeed brass eye yeah right chris
morrison sort of the godfather of that
second generation or you know
that sort of more modern era of um
pranksters where
their id because everyone knew who alan
funt was who did candy camera everyone
knew who jeremy beadle was and then so
the next iteration was what about if we
never break character right we make it
even more so in a sense merciless by not
having the moment where we show you how
funny you looked when we
made your car disappear and you didn't
know where it was right so i came into
tv thinking that that's really the
that's the funny space in fact based
comedy is is getting one over on people
but actually
that wasn't really i didn't really like
doing it that much and you know those
little first four days of of doing it
and i quite quickly evolved into a into
a different work mode which just
involved spending time with outrageous
people and being more of a straight
person because if you're a prankster
there in a sense the straight person you
know in the comic setting like where is
um the prankster is the funny the funny
one but i i don't really i'm not i'd
much rather be among people who are
outrageous or or intriguing or or
unusual interesting and just drill into
that
and so um but your question was about
did i have regrets did i think about you
know there were times when um i was
aware that afterwards the people that i
interviewed revisited what we did or
felt as though we weren't
fully
informing them about the nature of what
we were doing it was it was more the
exception than the rule there's
definitely things i look back at now
where i think
oh that's a bit painful oh that's a
slightly cheap shot or
why are you pushing quite so hard on
that it feels borderline harassive or
bullying what sort of thing oh
um
so some of them are in vo lines where i
think oh that vo line feels a bit
judgmental there's a moment in the
swingers program
where we arrive at the checkout counter
of a supermarket
i'm with the woman who's hosting the
swingers party she's very nice she's
very obliging and she's like
she's like now when we go in there don't
you know don't say that we're doing it
for a swinger's party okay because
people can be very judgmental so then
we're the checkout counter and i started
going margaret margaret maybe we should
she's quite attractive shall we invite
her to the party
just to be a goof right and she's like
no don't mention it no but why don't she
might want to come to the party
and she no don't mention the party and
it's not it's not like horrible it's
just it's just a sort of needling you're
not taking it as seriously as she is
it's fake it's a it's it's it's a tiny
bit like when i watch it now i'm like is
it that funny or is it a little bit
unkind there's another one i mean it's
going to sound really trivial to you
because it's these are in the judgment
like it's all in in the
in the roster of crimes of television
that i've committed these are relatively
uh small but but but but this was the
question that was asked right so another
one is when i'm talking to a guy called
troy houston who's a pawn performer and
he's gay for pay is the term
and and then after he's done his and and
i'm like well are you really straight
and just being gay for pay or are you
actually bisexual right or gay right um
after he's had his gay sex for the for
money in the porn scene
he goes uh well i i said what so what
did you have to do you gave the guy
[__]
yeah i can't remember the exact line but
he goes like unfortunately
and then something about that wrangled
right like i thought well if you're
gonna do it
don't be like
unfortunately like be like yeah you know
what i mean you can't have it both ways
i mean judgmental i know i might have
been wrong that's why you guys
unfortunately a bit of an enthusiasm
that's what they were saying so i heard
myself say oh come on you enjoyed it
right or something like that
which which again was i think i'm it's
not the worst thing in the world it was
me i'd have to see it again no but
the strikes was a tiny bit unfair and i
remember in the edit there was a
conversation about shall we take that
bit out right and at the time i was like
take it out what are you talking about
that's one of the you know funny bits in
the in the film but but evidently the
director and the series producer were
like oh that's really on the edge of a
bit mean or maybe even i don't know no
because he's bullshitting himself
because there are some things you can do
and be like yeah unfortunately like you
know i i don't know you may not have
swept the house up properly all right
right yeah he's using a word that
doesn't fit with the [__] putting a
dick in your mouth and then ju and
getting on with it you know what i mean
like yeah that in some of you well
unfortunately but also it doesn't fit
what he did right it didn't need a
response it needed a response absolutely
but so i went so i probably should have
said um
so you didn't enjoy it at all that would
have been fine right but what i said was
come on you enjoyed it a bit or
something like that but i quite like
that and also but also i wonder if you
take those things out then i don't see
how part of what i like is watching the
relationship between you and the people
you are with developed one of my
favorite ones
was when you became sort of friends with
the problematic prostitute uh in that
brothel house where originally you had
this really
sort of edgy relationship where she kind
of was testing you and clearly i mean
she didn't have great relationships with
men kind of bullying you a little bit
but but you stayed with it and
eventually won her over and became quite
friendly it was a lovely
awk yeah yeah haley was her working name
and uh she
in her first interview was very obliging
and but just
obviously intelligent and thoughtful and
reflective in a way that um to me was
surprising at the time and um and and
then
which kind of real i know she got my
number or she was she was shrewd and she
figured out that she needed to take
control of the situation and so she said
like i'm not going to do any more
interviews unless you book a party with
me which is the term
and um
and so i feel like you had to kind of
win her over and once you did that
you went in then then then we did we i
booked a massage which i paid for out of
my own money no license pay money went
for that and went towards that that's
fine yeah i remember i was coming
towards much worse things i already i
had polish neighbors at the time and and
on the day after the program went out i
arrived back at my house
in halston and uh the neighbor he was
quite a grumpy old man and he and he
said i see this program and for this we
pay our license
this is not often you get you normally
people only bother to give you feedback
if it's positive but actually to be
reprimanded by someone who's pissed off
i'm not actually from the country uh
well he's basically he's uk you still
you're still going to pay whether you
have a tv either you've got
to pay for long lawrence right the
question is a very good point um
so when you when she's on this is the
thing i wondered she was a what many men
would consider attractive woman tall
blonde good boobs and bum all of that
was in place
and you're obviously a guy in a
relationship at the time she's
straddling you massaging you
um and you seemed quite sort of
nervous oh it was it was it was it was a
lovely moment to sort of watch you but
were you feeling
attracted to her was that a difficult
thing for you to go through uh
even though she wasn't your clearly you
weren't on a wavelength romantically but
it's a naked woman on top right you know
hand on heart i wasn't it wasn't for me
an erotic encounter it was it was it was
awkward it was embarrassing
and um and that was exactly what she
wanted out of it
and i think oddly though in in disarming
me
you know and realizing how um almost
defenseless i was in once it's like kind
of in a sense you know figuratively but
literally also naked all i had boxes on
i think in disarming me she sort of
disarmed herself because i think she was
surprised that i did it i think and i
think when she saw you know how
it's it's hard to be angry at someone
who's defenseless and i think she had
her danda was up a bit she was you know
she i think she'd been feeling a bit
like what am i getting out of this
documentary i've given him a few
interviews why should i even do this
unless you book a party then i'm not
even going to give you then once i did
it she get she gets all giggly and she's
like saying all kinds of things and and
then although i'm sort of awkward and
embarrassed to be there but i can start
asking questions and doing interviews
during the during the massage and then
she answers them
very uh very candidly
because you proved you weren't above her
and maybe she was thinking that at the
start like who's this british journalist
coming in but now you're literally there
half naked on her table and you're
clearly saying look i i don't think i'm
better than you i'm willing to be a part
of this or to a degree
i think that that really
uh
as someone who may want to make
something like that one day it was a bit
of a lesson for me yeah all right okay
specifically the prostitute well no i
mean i'm just checking it was it was
admirable the way you just got your sort
of hands dirty sort of well i appreciate
that you know in the end um
you know that kind of participation in
in in a documentary it has to be
uh
handled in quite a careful way and i
think
to to be there and say like i'm gonna
get a you know massage from a working
goal um it could be crass and and
actually because she dictated the terms
and even with her dictating the terms
it really needs a lot of thinking
through and and um you know and it
wasn't totally straightforward on the
home front like you can imagine like i
was i wasn't married at the time but i
might the woman who is now my wife
was my relatively new girlfriend
in fact one of the things that told me
what a special person she was was the
level of kind of coolness and and sort
of
self-possession she showed when i showed
it to her
like she wasn't gonna let me see that it
bothered her but she's like she just
said
oh you are flirting with her a bit
and like she just clocked it she knew
exactly what was going on
but she's like i'm not gonna um make a
big thing out of it it takes quite a lot
of there's um you do show her quite a
bit of your work don't you like there's
a point where you talk about showing her
a meth doctor yeah yeah yeah she tells
you 20 minutes in that's the first time
you smiled in the documentary yeah she
thought i was going down the kind of the
not the wrong she felt like i wasn't
playing to my strengths
in in the sort of documentary i went i
went for a while i realized that me in
dangerous or semi-dangerous settings was
a kind of winning formula for um for
documentaries you know you're always
looking i i did almost the hardest thing
in in the work that i do is just finding
the initial idea like what is the space
the subject the theme that will allow
you to get 60 minutes that will have
light and shade a compelling narrative
actuality unfolding on screen
so for a while after i did one about san
quentin prison
i thought wow this which got six million
viewers which is really high for us i
thought this is a great um this is a
great kind of seam of material because
um i i can just find other settings that
promise some kind of danger whether it's
embedding with in high crime areas of
american cities or other cities or
you know investigating drug use in in a
kind of real world so so i did that for
a couple of years and then
i think it got to the point where
so it was becoming a bit it was in
danger of becoming a bit one note and
she she picked up on that that was in
that was in quite a sort of a weird
period as well in your relationship i
think in that point in the book you're
talking about two young children yeah i
was away a lot
and um
you know
i think like a lot of women who have
kids and have successful careers but
then take time out from their careers in
order to be more around
for the for the kids like she was she
was
uh so pulled in two directions between
missing work but also wanting to be
present for the family and i think
resented
um the fact that i had made fewer
compromises whereas i mean i talked
about all of this in in that book that's
the middle one
got to get through this where my parents
both worked so i um
i was used to having a an au pair who
who would come and be there when i got
home from school and um and my dad would
go away you know he's a travel writer
would go away sometimes for months at a
time and so i thought oh well this you
know we all sort of bring in a sort of
sense of expectation of family life
based on what we experienced growing up
right so i sort of thought well you know
if you want to be back in the workspace
that's fine we'll just bring in a
notepad she's like no no i don't want
someone else looking after our kids i
want
one of us looking after them and i think
it shouldn't always be me
and that became quite a big um
butting of heads point you know i i it
took me a while to sort of take on board
actually how much she was um really
going through you know with my absences
and looking back on it you know if i
made three films a year which i tended
to and they each required uh a you know
up to four weeks of filming that was
really about three months that's a
quarter of the year you know and that
that with young with a young family that
you're taking a lot of kind of emotional
equity out of the bank what happened in
the there's a point in the book that i
was kind of interested in is when you
said there was a sign that you
completely overlooked or it didn't quite
strike you when you were in a fancy
hotel with embroidered uh robes
and she tells you something at that
point what uh she said um
oh she said uh if you were ever thinking
of having a um a relationship outside
the marriage
or or like straying i can't remember how
she phrased it she said i would be okay
with that and what and what and at that
point i think and i was like oh well
that's cool like i'm not gonna
like i i you know i one of the like i'm
i'm kind of i don't know if a lot of men
are like this i tend to think more more
are like than women i know like those
kind of secrets i'm worrying that this
was a trick question just to see what
you'd say
yeah you know what i mean but yeah you
can you can straight right yeah it was
actually
the thing that was gonna there was
actually a hidden camera in the room it
was a bbc documentary they were making
on you at that point and you [__] it
all up because you just basically went
yeah fine instead of going hold on a
minute and then they'd burst out and
gone surprised yeah yeah took it a bit
farther no it was funny it could have
been it could have been like do i don't
i'm a stranger to myself in many ways
like and i i don't always even know what
i'm feeling half the time right you know
sometimes it's like that you know
talking about that little man you say
like you're kind of angry
it sounds like it'd be nice if the big
man like you your totally integrated
self realize wow i'm angry i need to
calm down you know it would be nice if
in general
uh you know you knew what you were
feeling sometimes i catch myself
just think like i talk about this
in uh through the keyhole like it was
christmas i was quite hungover uh
because on christmas eve i'd gone to
town
on the bourbon and that was a fema and i
was like and and west you know e17 and
stay another day came on i was like this
is the worst song i've ever heard in my
life
and i just thought that what an evil
song one evil band like the group they
must be to bring out now obviously it
was all projection like i i what i
should have said is like wow
i must be
not just hungover really grumpy to pour
so much undeserved scorn on a completely
innocuous
song and group right
and um and and i think in general like a
lot of my emotions i tend to experience
almost by observing their effects like a
scientist as opposed to experiencing
them like a human do you know what i
mean
you don't come across as the most
emotional guy ever that's right in in
your documentaries
that was one of the things that sort of
struck me as part of the brilliance is
obviously you're not showing too much
emotion and therefore people don't
really know how to read you but a little
do they know it's because you're not
really sure what to think about it or
feel about it yourself as it happened
that yeah it very rarely
did i see a tia come to your eye do you
think is that something that maybe that
mrs has mentioned to you about you could
be more emotional or is that something
that you think is a thing that you've
struggled with or is that fine uh okay
interesting question she doesn't say you
know whether or not i think she thinks
i'm kind of an emotional
um
idiot like in other words like i'm not
an emotionally mature i think she would
say i'm not an emotionally mature person
which obviously she doesn't make a habit
of saying i think if you asked her she
might say that um
which obviously if she said you know and
we all say things in if we're having a
row or something that we
that aren't the kindest things but but
might be based in some kind of truth and
and i think when she's if she said that
obviously i've then thought well how
that's probably true right and and
actually isn't that odd that um
i'm in the line of work that i am
where which hinges on a certain degree
of
um
emotional perceptiveness right or or
some sort of level of psychological
acuity like one would hope like i i okay
i'm gonna
this is so this is me boasting i've
never mentioned this but we're not
posting but when i i was given i was i
was very proud to receive an honorary
fellowship in the royal college of
psychiatry like i made a number of
programs about mental illness i was so
proud like to get that you know i
haven't been knighted
and i haven't got a nobel prize
um
but um i am an honorary fellow of the
royal college of psychiatry which is um
which i just think like
is is you know taking what it's worth i
felt very proud to get it and and it
suggests they that they some medical
professionals in the field of mental
health so some of my programs have
thought well that guy seems to be doing
something positive and yet he my wife
according to my wife and i believe her
i'm also an emotional um emotionally
immature
person
so how those two things sit by side by
side i don't quite i mean you're a
documentary filmmaker which part of the
editing process alone
is storytelling and trying to make the
audience feel something which you
obviously do very well so i'm not saying
that you're an emotional
you know
well i wonder if almost that it takes a
degree of coldness and detachment to
to go into those worlds and um
it was something actually um
you know when i did i met up hey you
mentioned haley the the working girl sex
worker who who was at the the um the
brothel in nevada and a few years
afterwards i went and looked her up um
again it was for it was for
a book and um
and i met up with her in and she was
working as a waitress in a small town in
northern california and i talked to her
about she just wanted to hang out like
in a social setting and it was a
slightly awkward encounter where i was
there like oh i'm doing a follow-up you
know i'm in my professional mode and
then she's there like oh i just wanted
to hang out i thought you were a cool
guy like are you am i just material for
you and i'm like um
i don't yes kind of you know like which
made me feel obviously a bit shitty but
she's and then what she said was like
wow so you go around doing interview i
was like oh i'd like to do something on
pimps do you know any pimps and she's
like no though they're very you know
devious and
cruel people and the girls who go with
them are weak-minded or vulnerable or
have all sorts of complex psychological
needs like why would you even want to do
that like that's very dark and i'm like
yeah it's kind of what i do
and then she says you must be you either
must be very unfeeling
or extremely um or or have some dark
part of you that you even want to go
into those places like
i mean i only see that
she flipped it on youtube she flipped on
me and i and
whatever the case is i don't really know
but i do recognize that it's not
completely
uh normal right to actually in because i
do enjoy my work do you enjoy being in
um you know the two weeks
i spent at ko linga the mental hospital
for paedophiles
were
like two
very satisfying weeks of work because
you know people
you knew you were getting the material
though yeah and that's that feeling i
dodged that i didn't say happiest weeks
no i know but did you think i was going
to say that no but you would have been
it would be funny you would have been
happy as it was happening as it was
going on i felt as though it was um
just extraordinary like revealing uh
just
your that you're engaged like mentally
emotionally like everything about it and
it wasn't particularly hard work like
you they basically said well you can be
there during working hours from nine
till five so come five o'clock i went
back to the hotel the hotel was next to
a ranch where um
where they they basically
you know it was a butchery as well and
they had steaks it was a steakhouse
the hotel was attached to a ranch
steakhouse
and it was like i mean
people are going to be
you know saying i'm not paying my
license fee for bbc crew it wasn't
particularly expensive but that was
where we ended up don't worry about the
price it's okay he's always covering
this worth the money is what they say
the point is is that i was it was you
know it didn't i don't know whether that
was a normal reaction although you know
my i think my crew found it a kind of
interesting and stimulating intriguing
place to work as well so i don't know
that i don't know is it make me weird or
not going back to her criticism though
saying oh you must be really talk
if you look at the most viewed shows on
netflix or amazon they're all dark and
crime and rape and horrible [__] because
for whatever reason as people we're
fascinated by the darkness in humanity
aren't we so yeah it's interesting to
know where the line is so for example
the recent
um incident of child cruelty where the
child was um more or less uh beaten and
tortured to death do you remember this
happened over the whole you know
christmas and new year period they got
put away yeah the parents got put away i
think it was the stepmother had had done
it was it two mothers no it was a mother
and a father it was it was pretty
horrific it was absolutely well here's
the thing is i didn't really read about
that because
just seeing the picture of the kid um
was upsetting and and then reading the
details which i i imagined because i
didn't read it but i imagined would be
just something i didn't really need yeah
so there was a netflix documentary about
a kid who was locked in a cupboard and i
got halfway through that documentary if
that and i remember thinking i can't do
this anymore like it's it
i know i'm gonna like have nightmares
about this like and to me when you when
you start talking about the specifics of
what happens to a child for example you
know that is just too much for me to
watch yeah absolutely and by the same
token like the whole point of the koa
linga program wasn't like let's go and
hang out with some pedophiles and see
what they're all about it was actually
um that made you laugh it was just like
it was just a good way to be fair if you
pitched that i would have commissioned
because uh you know
it was like um
it was actually let's find out about
this place that purports to be able to
reform pedophiles and get to know those
pedophiles and sex offenders who are
making the most compelling case for the
fact that they may have been uh
rehabilitated so the
although there are a couple of
characters in it mr yarn and mr kitchens
we've mentioned who don't
embrace treatment they're single
encounters but the people we go on a
journey with the the three main
characters
are people who are deep into the therapy
and are making a plausible on the face
of it accounting of themselves
as having taken on board what they've
done that's wrong so so whether or not
they they have you know whether it's
authentic or not is debatable but
actually the premise of the program is
is there any road back for for an
ingrained pedophile at what point is
someone
what is unforgivable where is the line
you know
so yeah i think that it's like it's not
and i think that's what i probably would
have said to haley is like no i don't
want to go make a film and just see
um pimps being obnoxious i don't think
but i am interested in um
the the gray areas of relationships the
line between kind of the normal
the normal strains the the normal
anguish
which is which resides in all sorts of
intimate relationships and the line
where it becomes
something bordering on abusive right
yeah and that's what toxic which is and
it's not clear i've always done a great
job of that though
and showing that some of the
humanity and some of these people have
done these horrific things we did
another one thank you for that we did
another one like few years later we were
doing three programs about l.a
called la stories and we had two one was
about um
people on the edge of life in hospital
embracing last chance treatments you
know people with cancer brain injuries
in in non-responsive states and to see
how at what point do you say do you know
what i've done enough i need to let go
you're right or rather than torture
myself with false hope and expensive
treatments the second one was about dogs
in high crime areas and then we had a
third one about comedians that didn't
work out it was like well what do we do
now this one it you know this doesn't
have enough emotional angst so we almost
it's a lot you know sometimes when your
back's against the wall
you go for something that feels like
well we know we can do this because
we've been there before and we did one
about sex offenders in a small in a
small housing um in a little hostel
in an industrial area of la where they
all live together because of various
laws about where they can live they're
out on probational parole so that in
some sense free i'll remember this one
yeah but they're also monitored some of
them are on the edge of homelessness
they have to check in there's various
rules about what they can and can't do
and it was another one where um uh you
know how what's our justification but
because of the nature of the monitoring
it becomes it's really an examination of
again
how to how do we reintegrate do we
reintegrate people who've done dreadful
things at the point when they're
released but among the contributors were
one or two who we filmed and afterwards
it's like we can't put this person in
it's just too dreadful like it doesn't
feel you just watch it
and you just don't feel
good about even seeing it do you know
does that make sense yeah so so i i mean
it's a kind of long-winded
response to what you were originally
said which was like yeah we all enjoy
true crime many of us at least and and
dark themes but
i do also i think it's easy to overlook
the fact that there needs to be i think
for me anyway some redemptive quality
some quality of how is this enriching my
understanding of who i am who we are as
people
where is the hope you know where and
where where is the intriguing ambiguity
one great series i think that
i remember feeling everything that
you're just describing so you're very in
touch with your audience and what you're
trying to explain for sure because the
westboro baptist church
uh series was one where i was constantly
thinking is there any hope for these
people like where is the is that and
there was one girl who
i felt like you were hoping there was
some good in her as a younger person and
and you asked her like have you ever had
feelings about a man or whatever and she
sort of laughed and you could say like
you're in denial yeah like you're
clearly you know not what you're
pretending to be
and it it's like the blue pill of the
red pill like is she gonna
continue with this is she not and then
you come back years later and you see
now she's fully gone with it and there
is no saving her soul and if anything
now just like i think it might have been
a mother and elder
when she's saying horrible things about
gay people or whoever you can eat your
babies yeah she's uh
nice yeah she's uh she's laughing
now so she's gone from feeling
uncomfortable to embracing it and like
it's like some star wars kind of let the
hate flow through you and she looks
different yeah yeah and
yeah that that sort of was a great story
jail phelps and in fact
uh
it kind of uh my gifts of
prognostication are obviously not what i
would wish for in the sense that i
thought she had as you say some
part of her that was up for grabs right
in the sense of um salvageable like that
she would maybe see her way out of it
and you're i said something like have
you ever had moments where you strayed
or wanted that straight her face went
bright red and she went and she was it
was a half a laugh
sigh of despair like it was this really
odd moment of effect where she's sort of
um
so silly she's so silly so silly i'm not
gonna talk about that i'm not gonna
think about that and you see like oh
right it is present for her and it's
still real for her
and um
and the balance with her there there's
an element of cognitive dissonance in it
where she's kind of actively denying
what seems to be even true to her and
you're kind of you're awkwardly bringing
up the truth in that sense well i wonder
i almost think it's what it is is that
she's um
she's definitely i don't think it's
denial in the classic sense because i
think she actually knows exactly what
she's feeling
and i think um she's saying like i'm not
going to talk about that i'm not going
to think on it i don't even want to
she's like
she's like yes there's a little box in
here and and exactly what you're
describing is in it and of course i'm
not going to let you
look at it i don't even want to look at
it you know what i mean and um and the
funny thing about her was uh yeah she
was the one of the ones i thought who
she was what i thought might be up for
grabs she stayed but virtually all the
others the women the young women that i
spoke to left uh and made new lives for
themselves and when i went back for the
third one
jl felt
this one that stayed and became more and
more hardline
she seemed to become more embedded she
married a guy from do you remember from
where from from the north of england uh
oh yeah i remember that and he he felt
like a i mean he was an odd one you know
in america you're sort of like oh it's
kind of a culture there when they do it
from england it's even weirder to me so
it felt that it and it's kind of strange
because you don't seem happy either
exactly yeah obviously
i think that that sort of
comes with the territory of someone who
adopts that as is misery inside i felt
that but i also felt the other
documentary maker who had joined he was
trained crazy to be fair
if you think about him focusing on
subject matter though he was very good
at unpacking it you know he really did a
good job
he was a very smart guy yeah and i think
that was part of what made it all so
uncomfortable was a lot of those people
were living the lie and you had gone in
there and were very much presenting them
with it and it was even worse when the
englishman was there because in many
ways his personality was i'm english and
i sort of endorse this because i'm you
know it could just be you crazy
americans but i'm english and i'm over
here and then you are stepping in the
room and be like [__] another
englishman's here and he sees this is
crazy
that felt quite that's one of those
moments where when you were talking
about um you know being cruel or
undermining people that's where i
sometimes wondered how you felt
whether you were putting someone in such
an awkward situation and it led them to
such a horrible realization that you
felt uncomfortable doing that because i
had that feeling when i watched the one
about polyamory is it
where you take that's a good example the
partner outside and chat in the garden
and you basically and that's basically
your approaches
you're not you're not happy here are you
as basically what you were saying but it
was so difficult for them to unpack that
with you and you could see the cognitive
dissonance working in their minds well
there was a moment in that one where um
are they pregnant or something at that
point oh yeah that's right yeah i mean
oddly enough i think he was going
through something i think that he was
fine like i i don't i think it was a
um he was having an emotional low
when i see that i'm not troubled by that
material i think um he was so robust
enough to handle it and i think maybe
partly because they were young and
there was a lot going on and there was a
lot to be happy about in their lives
the guys who at the end but there was
also a family who
there there was a woman who was married
to a guy slightly heavy set out of shape
schlubby guy who um
they they
clearly they were somewhat physically
estranged right they were still making
the best show of
being together and making it work but
she was going in she would often see
this other guy with his
with consent from from her husband
and basically they had a kind of weekly
or twice weekly arrangement where they
would go and
park and have fun and giggle and be like
teenagers and then meanwhile
man number one is at home and he didn't
have like he had no
polyamorous uh person that he was having
the older guy yeah oh he was really
likable and you feel really sorry for
him because clearly
he's sort of he's kind of stuck in a
difficult situation and it's kind of
it's okay if behind closed doors you can
be humiliated but suddenly he's kind of
on tv and you're still going
well here's the thing because i have to
be some i i have to step back because i
recognize that you know all
interpretations are in their way valid
like i what what when i i s what i saw
was this guy's getting left out right
now more or less you deserve some
positivity
i more or less you put that to them sure
and and um and then they are very
politely and nicely
saying no no no
that isn't what it is like i you know
the man saying i'm fine and the woman
saying like he's fine and you know he
has permission to do what he wants and
and he hasn't found i'd love him to find
that person
and then he said and i say something
like um well is it an option for him to
come in on a three-way you know with you
and the other fella right
or or some i can't remember how it even
i think even he introduces it and he's
like if they ever wanted me to maybe
kind of stand and watch god i remember
the way you said it and i'm like i guess
i'd be okay with that and then her face
of like she's like she's sort of
thinking like biggest boner killer
yeah right to have my husband
watching and she's like i don't know
that i
would feel
that would be god and then you see his
little heart break in slow motion like
ralph wiggum yeah
he should have been able to test drive
being a cuckold even if that was just
sort of his didn't you just give it a
try and get the cuckoo level no beneath
that what is that on the couch what's
that called imagining it yeah exactly
yeah the best he's got is imagining his
estranged wife having sex at that point
yeah and you just got in there i feel i
have to stick up for cuckolds in the
sense that like this that's a thriving
subculture isn't it there's a lot of um
self-respecting men who enjoy watching
another man come in and
you know
the thing was also he first said like
maybe we could have a three-way and
she's like i don't know and then he's
like oh i could just stand and watch
she's like
i could be outside the door yeah he's
like well maybe you could write me a
letter about it yeah literally oh god
you know what is interesting about that
and that was something that was he
didn't say that he didn't say that yeah
but it was a good joke but the the
interesting aspect of that is and i
think what you um down the series when
it start when your first series starts
out a lot of it seems a bit more on the
nose shall we say yeah and as you go on
i think you
uh not that you need your own
documentary is evaluating to you but
what i find interesting is
along the way you begin to trust that
the audience will see it a bit more than
you need to give it or you need to show
that that's possibly true i mean i think
look that's a sensitive
psychological situation that they're in
can i and also just to stick up for him
for one moment we're not mocking him in
a bad way i think i quite like the thing
here's what so here's the thing what he
faces is a dilemma like there's an
aspect of the relationship something's
happening in the relationship that means
or in their makeup right that means that
she wants to go and have sex with
another guy what she was having with
that other guy was real like it was a
one for them wonderful like he loves
shaking her she loves shaking him good
for them if in a non-polyamorous
scenario i think there's a real um
realistic uh
possibility that she would have just
left him she would have thought i'm not
getting everything i need in this
relationship that's what she should have
done and then he is then
like a lot of like guys
uh in their 50s who who who aren't maybe
taking good physical care of themselves
who aren't maybe like
sort of super effervescent personalities
he would be living like the kid no
longer has two parents under the same
roof and he's living probably on his own
or or you know like
his alternative
is not brilliant does that make sense
so he so so if you game out what i don't
know if you're suggesting this or not
what it looks like for him if he says
i'm not putting up with this you either
end it or it's over she's like fine i'm
ending it and then he's not not the
reason why she's strained though because
he's not that
guy with bowls who would say that he is
flat he's boring he's white rice as they
would say some people
it's just white rice and sat on the
couch right here
and i feel sorry for him because we like
you ever seen
me myself and irene where like she runs
off with the limo guy like i feel like
men like that jim carrey yeah i've
forgotten about the limit i filmed yeah
i just remember there's a transition
where they go from someone pooping to a
close-up shot of some
ice cream coming out
and that's the worry is one day she's
shagging this other guy and a shotgun
just comes through the door
but that's also because he's been put in
such a horrible situation and his
situation and that loneliness very much
reminded me of the early time when you
went to i think was thailand
and it was
it was so there was such a great uh that
this what you have is a good timeline of
i feel like you should hook certain
people up so that guy needs to break up
with the wife who's cuckolding him and
then you need to take him to your old
subject in thailand and go this man's
gonna sort you out sort of thing
yeah and then and he can look through
the a tape and the b tape and you know
work out what works for him but because
that was another aspect of love that was
quite interesting that kind of forced
love they were both in different kinds
of forced love remember remind me about
what this was so this is one of my
favorite ones and i think i say this the
most where the guy is clearly a very
angry englishman who's gone to thailand
to find a wife lake palmer lake palmer
was his name yeah i don't know if he was
angry but he was he had he definitely
had psychological needs based on having
been an army veteran he'd taken part in
a military action in aidan in in
whenever that was when 60s was it
and um that left him and it left him
scarred and he had anger issues it's
fair to say because i think he even says
it to you he's like
i think he says in the document i
watched it this week it is brilliant he
he sort of goes yeah uh and you say
physical sort of thing no no just
someone who has to be able to deal with
my verbal abuse so he sort of forgot he
said that so he sort of downgrades he
goes i don't hit them i just verbally
abuse them right and there's a very
awkward thing because you're in your
more playful mode
and then at the end he's found his wife
he's not married and i think i know
there's a part of me that was like hey
did he get married to this thai woman
because he wanted he knew that would
make him definitely be in the
documentary and it would make a great
scene for the doc you know that whole
idea about have we distorted reality by
bringing in cameras right and b
having therefore been played a role in
putting them together
um are we now responsible
or partly responsible if lake chops his
wife into little bits and hides her in
the fridge well that was quite funny as
well because the documentary pretty much
ends with him saying to her she can
barely understand what he's saying her
name is jad jad yeah and jad clearly
didn't want to hold hands on the first
date clearly didn't want to do all these
things that was a different date i think
yes yes i don't think that was jad i
think that was a different woman i might
be wrong maybe but the point is at the
end he goes we are no longer two people
we are one we are one and you and in
that moment you want to hear oh my god i
love you that's fantastic but she just
goes
i understand right and that for me was
like one of them it's the perfect end to
documentary because it shows so
brilliantly right that
she didn't understand if that makes
sense
look i you know part of my job is to
wrap my arms around things that may be
counterintuitive or confusing or
emotionally complicated right and and um
sometimes you know that's why my vo i
struggle to write like commentary on vo
because i i can't land is you know i try
not to be judgmental i can't always
dictate like with polyamory specifically
like i would say
that
it's killing me that i can't remember
his name but
what should happen there god knows like
the neither of those alternatives is
obviously perfect um and in general like
polyamory i'm sympathetic towards as an
alternative you know as we live longer
like when people got married i'm sure
you know like people got married like
the sacrament of marriage
was instituted as a as a thing like at a
time when people were lucky to live to
50 or 60 right so you would marry and be
married for 30 years now if you live to
80 or 90 you're married for 60 or 70
years not worth it good point and and
actually you've got to find ways of like
there's other there's myriad ways of
arranging social affairs that are um
that are just as valid as the ones we
use the other thing is that term
cockhold like i don't even it's not one
i hear very often except in a political
setting and and you know that term
cucked i don't know is it okay to say
cuckold or is that loaded now what
what's it loaded with so well
well no i just mention it because it's
the idea of i don't know uh well it's a
derogatory yeah i just wonder is there a
danger everything's offensive louis yeah
but in a sense like
maybe i've already made this point like
the idea i
i you know i have to be careful not to
become so open-minded my brains fall out
right but the idea that
oh you're less of a man because um your
wife is [__] some other guy i think
that's the point
that's what turns them on because in
general is a i don't know if it might
have been re-adopted by the polyamory
community i don't know but or is it a
way of saying because there is no
equivalent for women right surely it's
just that
only men are cuckolded right because
it's seen as a taking away
power is taken away a man's power is
taken away emotionally by a woman having
sex but a woman whose man is having an
affair there is no word for that because
no shame technically attaches to uh a
woman she's just married to a guy who's
who who shags i've i've heard i've heard
of a woman enjoying that before
that's a loaded story oh enjoying what
enjoying it's a queen well that's new
but that's that's a new that's a
neologism isn't it i guess so we're
where the guy fights you know we're
talking in front of his girlfriend and
basically goes this is better than you
and that sort of thing right that's
become sort of a genre i guess in porn
as well is like everything's a genre in
porn yeah yeah i think you know if
there's a louis vuitton no there
definitely is
i mean because
you've got like a a cult thing with
women like there's women out there who
are mad for you
what about that because you surely know
about this the world's smallest
subculture yeah
believe me it isn't if you had a
convention of them you'd have to book uh
a whole pizza express
wow yeah good show prince andrew
reference i thought not yeah not the ups
not even the upstairs of a pub no no you
you have this thing this is the thing
about you where and um you're you know
you're a handsome guy you have a
tall dark you know thing going on you
got a good demeanor very respectful uh
very approachable
and
a lot of women just have a crush on you
it's nice to hear that how do you handle
i don't hear that very often because my
time of life well when you got famous
surely there was a bit of a flood uh an
avalanche maybe you know
uh
i would say there was a small trickle i
was um
you're still talking about that
sorry
um
i'm kind of constitutionally um bound
monogamous
like i i don't do well i don't find
intimacy that easy like the whole yeah
we've seen that like the whole idea of
um
one night stands
i always found quite weird like not
weird as in i don't get it but i didn't
i don't know how you do that have you
ever tried i've tried not that hard but
i have tried yeah
i'm not sure what you mean by not that
hard
well i i've tried it in my years right
so time is
i haven't had
like i've had long relationships okay
and then small
sort of influence
yeah intermissions of of bachelorhood
and you know
you know
i've tried putting the moves that sounds
a bit weird i've tried to basically
um
yeah play the field a bit and um what
was the stopping point in your because
it seems like there was something that
you couldn't quite get to grips with
there
mentally
i mean physically i'm sure everything
was fine i mean i don't even know how to
break it down like those times when i've
tried you know those
occasions when i've thought um
are you on a date with a girl i'm trying
to imagine the scenario here of what is
why why you said you tried trying to
think like um like either i think a lot
of it happened
um
in my early or mid 20s at a point when
either i wasn't
famous or i was living in america where
i couldn't my fame didn't mean it was
surely being an english guy in america
though
that's a winner in new york it didn't
seem to work for me i mean i'm not
making sound like i made repeated
attempts like it just i think at some
level i thought you know i used to smoke
a lot of weed at that time that's good
and i'd be out like um
at a party or a club and i'd be like hey
how's it going yeah good nice one have a
few drinks and then towards the end of
the evening
i think you know i could
try to see if i can actually want to go
out can i get you one of it was i didn't
really want to play the long game like
hey should we go out on a date i just
think hey do you want to come back maybe
kick back and
smoke some gange and if that didn't go
then i'd be like you know i i'm quite
i'd like to go back and just
just blaze a j and just um have a not
like have another glass of wine smoke a
spliff and watch some tv or you don't
want the hassle of the awkwardness yeah
i just thought you know what i'm a
little bit tired
i i feel like i know that i can go home
and
have a spliff and read the new york
review of books and and put some music
on and get high and listen to some music
and that
would seem much more appealing probably
kind of shows where you're at yeah does
that mean it does that am i making it i
get what you mean though because you
mean a new person there's always that
sort of nervous energy of is this what
you want what do you like like you have
to break all of those things and with
someone like yourself who just kind of
wants that comfortable feeling of a
night aim as you're describing it yeah
that's sort of a bit much in it there's
a new energy you don't quite know and i
think where is it going to lead where
pressure yeah awkwardness yeah but
everything else in your career has been
partly about you sort of you know
not that your love life is your career
but in the rest of your life you do see
sometimes leave things down to
serendipity and you are quite willing to
go with serendipity so that's quite
interesting to see you're not willing to
do that in your love life well i wonder
if um
i wonder if one of the reasons that i do
the work that i do is because i um
it gives me the license or even the
incentive to to get out of my comfort
zone in a in a sp you know to explore
aspects of life
that if in my normal life i would just
be too passionate and that's what's the
brilliance of when i watch you is this
is clearly a man
who
look if you put me in that massage uh
position with that girl i'm confident
i'm happy i'm laughing probably grabbing
something the camera leaves the room
um i'm gonna adapt to it in a different
way but because that is clearly not what
you want to do that's the beauty of it
is is so funny and entertaining and and
also endearing
well that's nice of you to say i think a
lot a lot of my life is governed by
anxiety and and and and i think
with what and with that goes a certain
work ethic like i assuage feelings of
anxiety by
trying to work hard and be praised and
feel good about um doing work and
feeling as though you know it's like
delivering on a deadline or handing in
your homework you get that feeling like
oh i've done the relief
almost yeah i'm probably i would plead
guilty to being somewhat puritanical and
and and and then so in a setting where
um
anxiety like there's no work ethic that
impels you to try and go out and meet
someone and take them home right that
that all i hate what i'm mainly getting
from that is feeling of anxiety
and
where's the payoff and and and it's a
sense of yeah payoff of possibly further
anxiety and and is that why the ganja
came in handy right uh it was sort of
why i stopped smoking ganges
yeah i would i mean i would
i would um i i in those days i would
basically have a few glasses of wine and
then
that would take the edge off the anxiety
and then have a spliff and then i'd just
be
sort of almost i mean what you're just
on this sort of cloud floating yeah
you're floating i remember sometimes
lying in bed and feeling like the ready
brett kid do you know what i mean where
you you're kind of glowing right and
you're like and it feels
oh this is nice so how did you stop then
if it feels so good well when i met my
wife um she wasn't as big a fan
of of gange
of smoke there's a compromise you did
make yeah and and actually it doesn't
really work if one of you is doing it
yeah and the other isn't yeah you're
just wasted getting the munchies on the
couch and she's like well we've got
washing up to do yeah yeah come on
though pretty much put the kids to bed i
mean i would like to see it legalized i
would like to it was one of those things
like as i drink less i have ramped down
post pandemic
if we are post pandemic and um
if i don't keep bullet bourbon in the
house i find things go a lot more
smoothly right like i just have a couple
of glasses of wine or whatever but but
now that um i would love it if they
legalize it in california where i've
lived it's legal it's so civilized
it's it's you just um you know you vape
it or you do whatever and
it feels as though it's just the way
things should be right there isn't this
desperate
kind of like on nights out people don't
get annihilated at the pub right there
isn't that feeling of um
must get blotto
don't get violent on weed the health
ramifications are nowhere near as bad as
alcohol or tobacco it will happen it's
just happening so slowly we're waiting
forever in this country yeah and guess
what we've just spent so much money
on a truck and trade system that doesn't
even [__] work and you've got
something there that we could have
manufactured that would inject so much
money into the economy immediately and
yet we're not pressing that button
purely because alcohol companies decades
ago
waged a war against it to try and
preserve their own you know businesses
coming uh invest in it presumably
they're still lobbying against it
medicine companies will be as well
sleeping tablet companies all of them
and i get it but it's frustrating
because they're also prepping to get to
for when it does happen they need to get
the infrastructure in place
so what are they waiting for bloody hell
we need money i suppose the problem is
they're all sitting around smoking weed
so no one's getting anything they're
doing lanes in parliament right yeah
that's the other stuff that they like
that's quite interesting to hear you say
that though because obviously you're
sort of a bbc lifer um if you like
you're one of those people who's worked
with the bbc for majority of your career
your very own bbc at the same time well
my relationship with the bbc's changed
first of all i didn't come into the bbc
as a bbc animal like i was hired by
michael moore as a writer and presenter
on tv nation which was
although it was on bbc two like it was a
new york based independent production
made by his production of course you
were the intern in the office that did
all the photographs well he said that
yeah he got he misremembered it i'm very
grateful shout out to michael moore for
kind of giving
me like without him nothing that ever
that subsequently happened for my career
would have happened and and so i have to
i have to thank him for that and
and then i i was always certainly
detached from the bbc in that sense and
and i think and then even once i came
back to the uk first series of weird
weekends was made in new york then we
were outside even though we were
a bbc production we were based outside
the bbc for the most part and now one of
the things that happened two years ago
was
from being in-house bbc studios
production we stopped producing now we
produce programs with our own company
mind house so which is you and your wife
which is me and my wife and we also make
programs that aren't for the bbc
but i do think the bbc was extraordinary
i mean i think i am bbc in the sense
that um i think the bbc has this uh
because i think because of its position
in our culture
it's got the kind of the the the
almost the confidence to uh just give
latitude to people that someone in the
bbc believes it and they go like you
know famously monty python right the
famous story is like they went into some
commissioner and said oh we're a couple
of funny guys that you know a few funny
and they were like okay well we're only
commissioning one series you know it's
like based on almost nothing and then
you know and that's who else would have
commissioned like how would you even
have pitched monty python and for us for
me like for years and years when i was
in house i just had a rolling commission
they're like they i work contract to
contract ten they say okay make ten more
and that was what it was like make ten
more documentaries and then
whatever more or less whatever i fancied
doing it's extraordinary in a way like
we've talked a lot about a place for
pedophiles i find it hard to imagine
any other
broadcasting outfit in the world that
would have said hey
let's send this guy
to spend two weeks at a maximum security
of uh hospital for for pedophiles very
similar to working at the bbc at one
point
it's a joke sorry
and just ch and just see what you see
what happens right or let's go to san
quentin or in 2003 i said i want to go
and spend time with neo-nazis for six
months very similar to no there was no
pay
no but that's um sorry
no but it's strange for me because in
the dealings that people already know
about i think the bbc gets a bad rap on
savile and the pedophiles i agree and
sorry about that no we'll talk about it
anyway but
it's the fact that the bbc are so um
safety first generally in so many
different things i know you work with
them a little bit
and just what i've heard and then yet
with you they had so much trust yeah uh
i wonder how you
felt about that and how you managed to
get that trust really
well the first thing i'm thinking about
is one of the odd things was when i
delivered the program um
i thought no this is nothing like this
has ever been on tv you know
this is extraordinary like there's 700
of the most dangerous sex offenders
anywhere in california all housed in one
building and they're playing squash and
playing in jazz combos right and doing
finger painting to talk about their
feelings it was just whatever you know
the moral dimensions what you think
about that that's just an extraordinary
thing to get access to no other tv crew
had ever been there
and um and i remember what came back
from the channel at that time was a
feeling of like
yeah louie's getting a bit dark like
you know what about another
program about something that was more
like when louis met the hamiltons you
know
and and you know they've done so much
for me the bbc's i hate to sort of like
to do anything that implies criticism
but but i do remember thinking like well
that's quite odd like i thought they'd
be going like oh my god that was amazing
but you know i realized my sensibility
isn't for everyone and and that's part
of i suppose what makes it special
in terms of the um
the trust i think i get a lot of
latitude just but just from a track
record of delivering ratings and good
reviews right
yeah and to go with that you've probably
also got a team of people behind the
camera who obviously aren't you and they
are you know they're your counterbalance
if you like and i think a lot you do
sort of reference that in your book
where you say
you know uh like for instance when there
was an inquirer at the bbc you get
hauled in front of the inquiry but your
director your exec producer none of the
other people are involved in it do
that's right and they could have just as
valuable or information as you do if
you're more valuable i found that really
odd actually yeah was that because
you're the face of the operations that
was the savile inquiry the dame janet
smith several inquiries okay okay so i
was just getting at the toilet can i get
there
and then
are you okay for time how much longer
another 15. cool
let him piss really quick um yeah i
found that and i know obviously you're
quite reticent in a way to talk about
savile because you've been clipped up so
much and i know you know i i mean i
don't i if i'm asked about him i always
um you know i'm always up for answering
questions yeah i just didn't want to put
you in a difficult position because i
also get
it's kind of it's kind of something that
people know you for but not in a um a
lot of people haven't really properly
read into it and i and even well i think
here's what happens is that um
uh it's such a sort of clickbait topic
and i think anyone who speaks up
ends up almost it's almost like you're
tacitly saying
okay i'll be the face of this subject
i'll be the point person for this
subject but there's myriad people who
had closer involvement with him right
who had um
you know and i think the bb one of the
reasons the bbc
i mean clearly the bbc
didn't make him famous because he was
famous from pirate radio but elevated
him to stratospheric levels of fame to a
different level i think
most of his offenses uh if you if you
read the documents took place in
hospitals like there were offences in
the dressing rooms of top of the pops
and elsewhere on bbc premises but um by
far the the largest number of offences
took place as a leads general infirmary
in stoke management and stoke mandeville
and yet somehow the bbc
gets more of a wrap than the nhs when
actually you could plausibly make a case
that it was an nhs failure maybe don't
point that out because the daily mail is
waiting for both of them to kind of trip
up in that sense that's a bit worrying
well i mean it's i want the honest truth
of what you you know how you said that
you felt like the bbc got a bad rap
is that sort of what you're saying here
i think they've been i think it's
because there was a mis uh
there's no question there were huge
failings and the you know and i i anyone
who's really interested in this
i recommend that they read um the janet
smith inquiry these uh findings which is
quite a long document but at least have
a flick through they're all downloadable
on the internet and also
if you're feeling sort of um
masochistic like
or just genuinely kind of curious
in a macabre way about what happened the
the leeds general infirmary inquiry and
the um
the broadmoor inquiry and and the stoke
mandeville inquired every hospital every
school
uh had to launch a an inquiry and
publish its findings online and these
are all freely available
and um
and
what you so so clearly the the failings
were vast across the board
um he was given free reign of hospitals
more or less wandering the corridors in
a white coat sort of passing himself off
as a as a doctor
at the bbc
they obviously weren't observing you
know what was supposed to be the
protocols which was that no one under i
think 16 was allowed backstage and um
and and
so on their watch they carry that
happened on their watch and so that
those in charge carry the can for that
but and that's that and it
it was it was some of the footage as
well where you see him
groping kids in front of the camera as
well or inappropriately sort of they'd
hold them and it's disgusting but
i was wondering why you initially
asked the question to him are you a
pedophile like
what what information did you have like
i know there was rumors but
what what made you think you know what
because i've heard this that's why i'm
gonna ask him okay so the first thing to
say is that the reason i think just to
take one example on the bad rap question
like it's sometimes insinuated that oh
when louis made his program about jimmy
savile he he must have been told like
he's a national treasure and we don't
want it getting awkward like just bear
in mind
don't go too near
the questions about
whether he's a paedophile or anything
nothing like that ever happened in fact
if anything the reverse he was a he was
a risible figure at that point he you
know alternative comedy had come and
gone he jim will fix it had been off the
air uh you know you know and i mentioned
in the sense that you know it was a new
landscape of television making which
people like jimmy savile were seen as
superannuated and irrelevant and
hopeless he was known to be a supporter
of margaret thatcher anyone in media
tended to view him as a total dinosaur
right he wasn't under weirdo and a
weirdo and and he'd been on jim i'll fix
it and he hadn't um
he had he hadn't been on radio one for
many years and and so he was he was
retired relevant desperately trying to
get headlines by doing random stunts
um
on and
generating some sort of publicity i
thought that's why he loved being around
you because so when someone was giving
him any attention at all so so so uh i i
and the re so the the genesis of the
project was i was sitting around with a
bunch of people of similar age talking
about jim i'll fix it and it was like
everyone at the table was like oh yeah i
wrote in i wrote in i i said i'd written
in
um and i sort of realized what a kind of
level of cultural cachet or at least
sort of
just how many people had memories of him
and it was like yeah he's quite odd
wasn't he and i went back and talked to
my series producer david mortimer and
said
you know what about like a because we've
been thinking about a single profile we
talked about doing lemmy oddly enough
and bernard manning he was like yeah who
is there a single person who you could
spend a lot of time with and then they'd
be so intriguing and odd that you could
sort of go on a journey trying to figure
them out and what about jimmy savile for
this thing we've been talking about and
he's like yeah yeah yeah he's really
weird he's got you know he's got a cell
at stoke mandeville where he spends time
and uh or maybe he said at broadmoor
that's right he said he got a cell at
broadmoor
and he keeps his his mother's um clothes
in a closet and he gets them dry cleaned
once a year as a remembrance of her
cause of the duchess and and i was like
oh yeah and of course there's all the
rumors about him being a pedophile or
even a necrophile and he's like yeah
yeah yeah and like and just so just to
reflect the fact that for me that was
just general knowledge like that was
just that wasn't like media gossip that
was something i'd heard when i'd been
sort of 14 or 15 years old
and i never remember anyone ever saying
um oh wait wait jimmy savage supposed to
be a pedophile like i've never heard
that right you know when i um
when i uh when i went to make the
program it wasn't my aim to like unmask
him i didn't believe him to be a
pedophile i thought that um it was just
yesterday i thought it was just
something that gets passed around like
you know like people talk about
this actor uh put a gerbil up his bum
right
and he's a good actress
all right are you allowed to say no but
you know the funny thing about it is
no we're coming back to your old series
the guy in the brothel who thought he
was like richard gere and pretty woman
hilarious anyway sorry it's very
different richard
and took out an ad saying he hadn't done
anything like that which i believe right
i don't think he put up gerbil up his
body i approve this message yeah um i
don't think he did either
and rod stewart when i was growing up
they used to say rod stewart collapsed
on his way to a gig and was taken to
hospital where they pumped his stomach
and found the spur eight pints of sperm
belonging to like 15 different men right
who tested that you know i know it's
like it's a sticky something another one
yeah
and by the way and i heard that also
about mark almond i've heard that's it
about other people i remember being told
that
that uh mick jagger used to like passing
a pint glass around and getting everyone
like in his entourage to spit in it and
then he'd drink it right
i mean there's going to be some stories
about cliff richard as well another one
was he was very he's he's a famous you
know rock star ambiguous guy yeah um
so basically my point is is these things
get passed around and you think like no
i don't think that happened but it's a
funny story and that's kind of where you
settle i think in
your retelling or you know your kind of
um documenting of it all when i
documented it what happened was i i
didn't think um
he was probably a pedophile you know i
didn't completely rule it out but i did
think there's something mysterious
about his love life like i was like who
who who is
jimmy savile in the in the sort of
sexual sense like what's his orientation
i thought maybe he's gay i actually
thought maybe he's celibates like maybe
he's just like one of these people he's
like oh i don't like sex doesn't do
anything for me right and then i'll rock
when i um when i talked to him about it
he said i've got lots of girlfriends but
friends with girls
no i haven't got any of those so he was
suggesting he was like a kind of a
player a free bird a player a drifter
would go from woman to woman but with
you know wherever i
what is it
lay my hands
but that was kind of that kind of went
with the misdirection element well then
i thought like
um that doesn't sound very plausible
because like who would cop off with
jimmy savile like he doesn't have the
air of a don juan it just isn't
attractive enough
um so i thought well i don't really know
what the deal is but i mean the only
credit i can give myself is that i was
conscious of not having solved i knew
there was a riddle and i knew i hadn't
solved it you know in a sense like i
found the dimensions of the problem but
i didn't sort of figure out exactly what
you put the question to him and as an
interviewer that's all you can ever do
and i don't think you should be beating
yourself up about it but it did feel
like
when i watched you coming back and
talking to the victims i said earlier
that you hadn't been that emotional but
there was one moment where you were
talking to one of his victims and i seen
you
you were talking about how you felt like
maybe you hadn't done your best or could
have done better or whatever and she was
empathizing with you and and
i could feel like you sort of lost your
voice for a second possibly yeah yeah i
mean it was a it was probably the most
stressful
certainly the most stressful and maybe
the most emotional program i've made
because you know it's easy to not be
emotional in in situations where you
don't feel in any way
emotionally invested or or or in a sense
that you have no responsibility like if
someone's in prison
um for murder or in a hospital mental
hospital for you know um abusing
children
like that's on one level horrendous but
i've got no i got nothing to do with
that like that didn't happen i had
nothing nothing to do with i was a
thousand miles away but with savile
there was a feeling like oh i had an
opportunity to maybe i was thinking like
did i have an opportunity to do more and
actually and what part of me and the
other and i the other thing is like this
sort of feeling of um
of of of oh i and i i actually started
to quite like him like the word friend
doesn't really cover it but i had
friendly feelings towards him well he's
giving you great content in your head so
you're always going to be sure but also
someone's going to visit him though yeah
exactly i talk in my book about and in a
way the program speaks for itself i'm
proud of it it still stands up although
it's hard to find on the internet but um
uh what happened afterwards was that i
went to visit him a few times on these
sort of ambiguous um
uh outings where it would be like oh
he's going to do some publicity for a
dvd that we've got coming out or there
would be so it'd be semi-professional
but then there was a friendly element of
it where
um
i would uh we'd go to a local restaurant
me and my director of the original doc
would stay overnight at his place
so there was a part of me that that that
felt oh the line got blurred a bit and
and and i sort of viewed him as as a
kind of as a person i had friendly
feelings towards
and that so that was the part i found
more difficult uh to process was just
the idea that oh wow and when the when
the first allegations came out i just
noticed in me a little a part of me
thinking oh it can't be as bad as that
can it do you know what i mean like and
i and then i had as it became clear that
it was there there was a kind of a guilt
and a feeling of guilt yeah can you can
you describe that moment of when
the penny dropped of how serious and in
that maybe i don't know you're hearing
on the news and you're sitting down
thinking wow a guy who i thought was a
friend or a friendly feeling towards was
horrific and
like what was the dawning feeling well i
can yeah
obviously it's it it's a process right
and and what came first was mark
williams thomas in the exposure report
on itv then there was a panorama
that was also very powerful
uh there were various news segments but
for me
it didn't really fully hit home in in in
the sense i i got the
what was the most revelatory moment of
the level of his offending was reading
the um leeds general infirmary report
and and and
you can't really do justice to it on
television or because you know that
people are anonymized or they wanted to
but there's an accumulation of detail
because there's something like 50 or 60
victims all listed and you know not all
of it you know some of it
is rape or
some of it is sort of um
i mean what i'm saying is there's a
whole range of offenses
um
uh but because of the accumulation of
detail because the p the victims aren't
named they obviously feel they can sort
of deliver their testimony
without fear of um reprisal really a
sense of self-consciousness
and um
and you read it and it's a one after
another and then you reckon in
recognizing little parts of uh either
phrases or or just sort of seeing him
in your head as you read it
it's a very powerful and upsetting um
for you more than one people i'm sure
yeah absolutely and then when i made the
savile follow-up i made it my practice
to sort of read through the reports
anytime i was about to go and meet a
victim
just to keep it present just to keep the
level of the the realness the rawness of
of these fantasies in mind
so obviously there was a failure on a
lot of people's part
to
bring him to justice in in his life
um
people were let down but that there's
also a lot of people who think there was
a cover-up a deliberate cover-up because
of his relationships with certain high
figures in society and the positions he
held
what do you think of the rumor or the
speculation that he was supplying
children to certain people in power
as a way of keeping himself in the clear
similar as jeff jeffrey epstein did
uh i would i don't i wouldn't believe
that i i tend to think that if you look
at his offense history and also his
personality profile in general he was
very much a loner uh he was someone who
almost prided himself like he was he it
was it's intriguing actually because he
was connected to power in certain
respects but very much on his own terms
so he was famously a kind of a confidant
to um prince charles and and was
friendly with princess diana that's
where the speculation right and he was
you know spent the christmas at checkers
but
that weren't those weren't really the
circles that he moved in like based on
what i saw he prided himself on
surrounding himself with people who were
not in show business
who were uh sort of
just salt of the earth types who were
from leeds like his hairdresser the
bloke who lived downstairs from him um
local just local characters of a very
unstarry sort and when you read like the
the offences took place
not in a sort of epstein you know the
epstein ammo seems to have been get them
to his house get them to his mansion get
them to his island groom them over a
period of weeks months traffic them get
other people more of this operation
there's a whole outfit out riders like
you know maxwell and others you know he
had a he had a crew of people
who were
more or less running his you know or at
least involved in his um
his operation with with if jimmy
savile's offenses took place
in in hospital um corridors or in
on the spur of the moment sort of thing
yeah or most of the rooming issues
i mean it's the thing is he didn't
generally
i mean the thing is his offense history
was so vast and kind of various that
no generalization completely applies but
most i would say of his offenses took
place
as it were on the spur of the moment in
a moment of
if i put my hand here can i get away
with it if i grope here can i get away
with it and then testing the limits or
if i hug what happens if i stick my
tongue in this person's mouth or what
happens if you know i drop you know this
optician's coming around to deliver
glasses what's going to happen if i drop
my trousers we've seen that in your
documentary and how he would test the
limits yeah around people in the office
when he was getting undressed and stuff
like yeah but also because his
personality i think she says that the
optician went to his house she says that
was turned into a funny story in her
life well initially she wasn't
traumatizing right it's up for for her
to say whether she was traumatized or
not but the impression she gave was of
not having been traumatized by initially
although some you know people process
experiences in different ways i mean the
other thing is like then he there's
another woman who was at the end of the
film
who talks about um
having been assaulted
uh in some area of a church close to
stoke mandeville over various occasions
who in a sense i suppose she was groomed
in that it took place over some time
but even there he's not bringing her
back to his place he's obviously
opportunistically
finding a a private setting
where he thinks he'll be unseen and will
have a few moments to get his you know
his kicks by abusing her
so to me so it doesn't really to me make
any sense that he would deliver children
moving around the reason i understand
this a lot of people were like why is a
guy who is a crappy radio dj who isn't
powerful is hasn't got a lot of swaying
influence
have a lot more money than he should
have have this social status of a
charity guy then he's not been around
with the royals what the royals wanted
like an answer that and that's sort of
that's the speculation and i get it i
kind of get what they're on about but he
he first of all he didn't really have
that much money that was one of the
myths he created he'd get a new roles
every year sent to him and he traded in
the old one he had he had properties he
wasn't like he's his brand he was a bit
like a rapper like his brand was that he
was
really rich
and and he would give that impression
but that was part of his celebrity
persona
i mean i'm not saying he was hurting for
money but like he wasn't like you know
like he was had about as much money as
an average
business person do you know what i mean
and um with respect to uh
he he wasn't also wasn't a crappy dj
like he was quite an accomplished dj
like he's one of the things that's
happened in retrospect is like because
his defense history was horrendous like
it's like it's almost over everything
about him
has to be awful like he was actually an
accomplished uh caster broadcaster he
was i've seen him deliver uh pieces to
camera on the spur of the moment without
any pause without any repeat like in a
single take perfectly to time that's not
an easy thing to do
and quite evidently like to run a
successful family show like jim will fix
it as a presenter
for more than 10 years with huge ratings
like
that it's not a trivial achievement
um so and the idea of his influence was
he what he did have because he had no
family
and because he had um
you know predatory sexual interests
and maybe even for other reasons as well
like he dedicated himself to charity so
through his leveraging his charity uh
work which was you know considerable and
raising millions
thereby he got the ears of people in
power
and you know if you say i've just raised
20 million or whatever to build a new
wing of a hospital
then in general like someone powerful
will show up to cut the ribbon right
it's quite manipulative though from his
perspective
yeah as it turns out like that was a
part of his offense
practices right can i ask you because
that's what i was curious about did you
feel
manipulated by him because there was a
point where i was reading a book where i
did feel a bit like he would have he'd
have your phone number and he'd call you
and he would sort of he'd take credit
for little things there were very
there was a lot of manipulation or
attempts at manipulation
uh towards you i felt in hearing of
course yeah i mean
i was one of many people i mean i would
say anyone who imagined was um powerful
or had something that he thought might
be helpful to him he would attempt
to manipulate
right i mean that was his that was his
thing that was his entire mo and
occasionally i'd be surprised like i
think of him as quite a friendly person
and um and accommodating and like one of
the things i liked about him was that he
was unfussy right he was he he wasn't
deverish in the least right he was
actually so for example on location my
director accidentally broke one of the
windows of his house and he just laughed
about it or we also accidentally
broadcast his address
which is a big no-no in um
you know tv terms like he he's a
celebrity he shouldn't have his address
put out on tv that should have been
blurred
um because it was in shot and and he did
he just laughed about it and i thought
good on him like you know
he he actually he could have thrown a
fit or been upset and up tight as many
other like max clifford for example was
difficult you know he didn't like the
documentary he kicked up a fuss he got
annoyed he got vowed revenge
jimmy savile was like oh no it's a good
program i'm like what do you need from
me in the way of publicity and then in
hindsight you realize oh all of these
are
ways of ingratiating himself and ways to
create a feeling of indebtedness
that then builds uh a kind of gratitude
and a trust and a sort of sense of good
will so that was his whole mo and it was
you know obviously very effective i wish
we had longer because it's sort of open
we'll do another one i'd love to because
it does open up that whole other
conversation about we we have a lot of
conspiracy theories on and i'd love to
have heard your opinion about people
well i'd love to talk about that i do
think that like that what you mentioned
brian about the you know was he
trafficking like
i'm i think the the world of um
pedophiles and sex rings you know is
real like those things exist but they
don't exist in quite the way
um that is maybe commonly understood in
in the sort of the world of internet
conspiracy theories and i think it's a
it's a it's a big deal because obviously
q anon has got so much traction and it
shows a rather i think naive
understanding of how
um how trafficking takes place i've made
a program about trafficking in houston
how sexual abuse takes place
and and the ways in which it does
flourish but but but not quite in in in
the sort of in the queue and on
mode that is kind of where i'd love to
unpack like the fact promised us another
podcast now is i mean that's
contradictory
yeah um that is contractual you are
going to have to come back yes
let's see what the headlines are like on
this one yeah we'll go with it oh
they'll be [__] great just remember
true geordie podcast if you could get
that in the daily mail always seemed to
take the quote but they
normally we'd go with the um i was
friends with jimmy savile headline but
but we've also got the like i was on the
edge of having a drinking problem i do
like that i do like the drinking problem
was good because i feel it humanizes you
a bit yeah i think you should go down
there shouting at the kids as well
abusive dad yeah exactly yeah yeah and
i'm sure you're thrilled to hear us just
joking about that at this point
it's all in the book through the keyhole
and more i was very struck by the way
how candid you are in your book my wife
and i have sort of enjoyed we've enjoyed
how candid you were because it
normalizes some of my awful behavior
nicely thank you for that nice to hear
that be the best person you can be the
best dad that you can but if you can't
drink bourbon well i wasn't going to go
sorry there
one one more question before you go yes
how would you like to be remembered
oh
that's that's a that's a good one i mean
i normally have a joke for that which
i'm not even gonna you know the joke is
obviously like oh
you know he he died having sex in the
arms of his beautiful wife nancy on
holiday in crete you know celebrating
that he'd received his long-awaited
nobel prize that he'd rejected i
honestly wondered what you were well you
were going to receive then that was yeah
uh uh but you know
i would like to be remembered you know
the most important people in my life
obviously my family my kids i'd like to
be remembered by them like as a
you know
my wife will outlive me i'm sure
you know as a like a guy who didn't
always shout as his kids like who was
actually a considerate loving dad like
i've got three boys families as they get
older they don't get simpler they get
more complicated i see families people
close to me they get estranged from one
another they fall out if you can keep
your relationship with your kids as you
get older
and and just be loved and remembered by
them as someone who who is a present dad
a loving father someone who gave them
the best start in life a loving husband
who who was um you know who who you
spent you know i'm thinking about my
wife now who who you enjoyed spending
time with you know like these are the
simple things but they're also the big
things
beautiful beautiful ladies and gentlemen
louis theroux thank you jordy podcast
great one thank you very much like the
video subscribe and we'll see you on the
next one